İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar 13 Ocak 2025 Pazartesi günü 55. ders günümüz saat 19.30 dersimize başlıyoruz kaldığımız yerden devam edeceğiz ses ya da görüntüde problem olursa bildirin lütfen değerli arkadaşlar.
Nerede kaldığımızı şöyle bir hatırlayalım evet formatlama interfezi o stream ve iStream sınıflarında en son yazma alanı genişliği ve yazma alanı genişliği içindeki alignment hizalamaya değindik burada iOS left iOS right iOS internal bayrakları vardı bunları açıkladık ve alan bayrağımızda
iOS'un adjust field'iydi sola dayalı sağ dayalı ve internal yazım biçimi sola dayalı sağ dayalı açık ama internal işte ekranda gördüğünüz gibi işaretler alt alta sağ dayalı şekilde sayılarda alt alta hizalanmış şekilde aslında internal ihtiyacı çok daha az ortalama ihtiyacı daha fazla ama zamanda verilmiş kötü bir
kararla C++ standart kütüphanesi kararına destek veriyor oysa C++ 20 standartıyla dile eklenen format kütüphanesi arkadaşlar iOS'un kütüphanesi böyle fakat format kütüphanesi ortalamaya olanak veriyor dedik.
Şimdi sanırım alan bayraklarından bir de ne kaldı arkadaşlar alan bayraklarından bir de sayı sistemi onu konuştuk pardon sayı sistemini konuştuk gerçek sayıların yazımı.
Arkadaşlar tıpkı c'deki printf'de olduğu gibi gerçek sayıların yazımında aslında 3 ayrı yazım biçimi var.
Burası biraz karmaşık.
Şimdi birinci yazım biçimine İngilizce'de fixed deniyor.
Fixed yazım biçimi demek noktalı olarak yazmak demek.
Yani nokta ve noktadan sonra basamaklar.
Scientific demek 10 üzeri çarpanı şeklinde yazdırmak demek.
Yani formatlama örneğin 1.2 çarpı 10 üzeri 3 gibi.
Ama bir de fixed ya da scientific olmaması durumu var.
Bu durumda sayının büyüklüğüne göre belirli bir büyüklüğe kadar fixed olarak onun üstünde scientific olarak yazıyor.
Yani belirli kurallara göre o ayrıntıya değinmeyeceğim.
Kendisi karar veriyor.
Arkadaşlar burada alan bayrağı flood field.
Yalnız burada ilginç bir durum var.
Eğer fixed ya da scientific ikisi de set edilmemişse işte o zaman az önce söylediğim 3. mod.
Yani büyüklüğe göre kendi karar veriyor.
Fixed set edilmiş fakat scientific set edilmemişse fixed.
Scientific set edilmiş, fixed set edilmemişse scientific.
İkisi de set edilmişse bu durumu hex plot deniyor.
Hex plot olması durumunda gerçek sayıyı 16'lık sayı sisteminde yazıyor.
Evet.
Alihan Bozkır'a sorusu.
Hocam set F fonksiyonuna 2. parametre olarak bir alan maskesi veriyoruz.
Bu maskeyi PMT flag ile maskenin değili bitwise end yapıldıktan sonra 1. parametredeki flag ile orlanıyor mu?
Evet.
Yani aslında geçen derste de biraz anlatmıştım Alihan Bey.
Şöyle şimdi bizim alan bayrağımız şu olsun.
Aslında bu arkadaşlar üstünde işlem yapacağımız bitler şunlar olsun.
Alan bayrağımız da şu olsun.
Buraya belirli bir değerin yerleştirilmesi için önce buranın sıfırlanması gerekiyor.
Yani bu bitlerin reset edilmesi gerekiyor.
Bu bitlerin reset edilmesi için, şuraya da sıfırları koyalım.
Arkadaşlar, tıpkı Alihan Bey'in dediği gibi bu maskenin değiliyle V'lememiz gerekiyor.
O işlemden sonra ilgili bayrakla V'lememiz gerekiyor.
Aynen dediğiniz gibi.
Yani %100 doğru.
Arkadaşlar, şimdi bakın gerçek sayı formatlamasına diyelim ki bir gerçek sayımız olsun.
Double, D var.
Eşittir.
Şöyle bir sayı.
I'll stream başlık dosyası.
Ve burada
Display, PMT isimli bir fonksiyonumuz olsun.
Arkadaşlar, stud.ios.rep
ios ya da i ya da x
if
x nokta
flex
itself ve
ios'un
arkadaşlar, stud.ios'un
fixed'i
stud.ios'un
fixed
set
as
fixed
aynısını
scientific için yapalım.
ios'un
scientific değeri
ve
scientific
Evet, şimdi bu fonksiyonu çağıralım.
display
pmt
put
cout
Önce
şu andaki state'e bakalım.
İkisi de
anset.
Gördünüz değil mi?
Şimdi bakınız
cout
arkadaşlar
deval
hatta
şöyle diyelim, buna
devir
diyelim.
Bir sayı daha
alalım.
d2
bu da büyükçe
bir sayı olsun.
d1
biraz boşluk
e2
new line
arkadaşlar görüyorsunuz bunu fixed olarak yazdı.
bu değeri ise scientific olarak yazdı.
Bu default durum.
Şimdi
fix maskesini set edelim.
Arkadaşlar
cout'un
demin işte
Alian Bey'e söylediği fonksiyon
set f
stud
ios'un
fixed'i
ve
float field
yine yazdırıyorum.
Sonra
bu sefer
scientific
ve yine yazdırıyorum.
yazdırıyorum.
Ve
bakınız
arkadaşlar
arada
hatta
şu fonksiyonları da çağırayım.
Daha şık olsun.
Bakın
fix set
scientific
unset
ikisini de
fiks olarak yazdı.
Fixed unset
scientific
set
ikisini de
scientific yazdı.
Ama bir şey daha yapacağım.
İzleyin.
cout'un
set
f'si
ios'un
tut
fixed'i
her ikisini de set ediyorum.
her ikisini de set ettim.
Ve görelim
gerçekten.
Bu duruma ne deniyordu?
Hexplot
heksatesman sayı sisteminde yazacak.
Her ikisi de
set
ise.
Bakın
fixed set
scientific set
her ikisinde
16'lık sayı sisteminde yazdı.
bu örnek önemli.
Bunu kitaba da koyayım.
Ve şimdi
biraz da
precision'dan bahsedelim.
Arkadaşlar
precision kuralları
biraz farklı.
Eğer
fixed olarak
yazıyorsa
precision'un
bir default değeri var.
Yani örneğin
cout
d
şimdi bakın
yazdırıyorum.
Görüyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
noktayla beraber
eğer şöyle
olsaydı örneğin
şu anda
yalnız
fixed
notasyonda değil
görüyorsunuz
6'ya yine
tamamladı.
Ama
fixed olsaydı
noktadan sonra
altı basamak
olacaktı.
Bunları akılda
tutmanıza
gerekiyor.
iOS'un
fixed'i.
Arkadaşlar
şaşırabilirsiniz
normalde
şöyle yazmam
gerekiyor değil mi?
iOS'un
float field'i.
Ama zaten
başlangıçta
her ikisi de
an set olduğu için
şimdi sadece
fixed set edilecek.
Gördüğünüz gibi
noktadan sonra
altı basamak.
ama
tıpkı
daha önce
gördüğümüz
arkadaşlar
fill fonksiyonunda
olduğu gibi
tıpkı
daha önce
gördüğümüz
width fonksiyonunda
olduğu gibi
burada da
sınıfın
precision isimli
bir fonksiyonu var
taban sınıfının.
Yine
3 fonksiyonunda
ortak özelliği
eski değeri
get etmesi
yeni değeri
set etmesi.
bunların
3'ünü birden
bir göstermek
istiyorum.
Fill neydi?
Doldurma karakteri.
Mesela
bakınız
auto
c
eşittir
static
cast
int
efendim
see out
un
arkadaşlar
fill'i
default olarak
doldurma karakteri
32'in oğlu
ask karakteri.
see out
fill
karakter
code
is
görüntüsü
yok ya
arkadaşlar
c
görüyorsunuz
değil mi?
Ama şimdi ben
şöyle bir kod
yazsaydım
c
eşittir
see out
un
fill'i
diyelim ki
arkadaşlar
doldurma karakteri
olarak
artı karakterini
kullandım.
Şimdi artık
fill fonksiyonunu
parametresi
çağırdığımda
geri dönüş
değeri
arkadaşlar
artı karakteri
olacak.
Yani
parametresi
çağırdığınızda
get ediyor
parametre ile
çağırdığınızda
yeni değeri
set ediyor
eski değeri
get ediyor.
Yalnız
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
char olduğu
için
stream'e
verirseniz
onu karakter
olarak yazar.
O yüzden
burada
static
cast
operatörünü
kullandım.
width'i
zaten
biliyorduk.
Şimdi
gelelim
precision'i
arkadaşlar.
Auto
hr
eşittir
see out
un
precision'i
bakın
default
precision
değeri
az önce
söylediğim gibi.
Ama
şimdi
bakın
see out
precision
ya da 12
Cout
Setf
iOS'un
Fixed'i
Cloud Build'i
Cout
Arkadaşlar
ne diyelim
45 nokta
noktadan sonra 12 basamak
yazacak
anlaşıldı mı
arkadaşlar şimdi geldik çok önemli
bir yere
buradan sonrasını iki kat dikkatle
takip etmelisiniz
şimdi gördüğünüz gibi
buraya kadar öğrendiğimiz kompsiyonlar
on-off bayraklarını
set eden setf
reset eden
an setf
bir de
birden fazla seçenek olması durumunda
ikiden fazla seçenek olması durumunda
yine setf'nin
iki parametreli overloadu
bunun dışında
doldurma karakterini
get ve set etmek için
fill fonksiyonu
precision'i set et ve get etmek için
precision fonksiyonu
yazma alanı genişliğini
set etmek için
ve get etmek için
width fonksiyonu vardı
width fonksiyonu dışında
yazma alanı genişliği dışında
bütün değerler kalıcı
ama yazma alanı genişliği
sadece neyi bağlıyor
arkadaşlar ilk yazılacak
öğeyi
yani
stream'e ilk insert ettiğiniz
değer için
yazma alanı genişliği
etkin
sonra
eğer tekrar set etmezseniz
otomatik olarak
sıfır değerine set ediliyor
fakat şimdi
burada çözülmesi gereken
bir problem var
arkadaşlar
çıkış işlemleri
çoğunlukla
bir derste bundan bahsetmiştim
ama şimdi
daha da fazla bahsetmemiz gerekiyor
çıkış işlemlerinde
tipik olarak
chaining tercih ediliyor
şimdi düşünsenize
siz
diyelim ki bir stream'e
önce x'i
sonra y'yi
bunlar farklı türlerden olabilir
sonra
z'yi
veriyorsunuz
böyle bir
statement yazmak istiyorsunuz
peki
x'i y'yi z'yi
farklı formatlama özellikleriyle
yazdırmak istesem
chaining bozulacak
örneğin
x'i yazdırdıktan sonra
y'yi yazdıracak
formatlama özelliklerini
set etmek için
ayrı
set f fonksiyonu
with fill gibi fonksiyonlara
çağrı yapmam gerekecek
işte
bu tür problemlerin
çözümü için
elimizdeki silah
ingilizce karşılığıyla
o stream manipulators
arkadaşlar daha önce bu konudan
biraz bahsetmiştim
ama
bir hatırlatmak istiyorum
şimdi bakın
bir hayli karmaşık gibi görünüyor
ama özü çok basit
demiştim ki o derste
o stream'in şöyle bir
sınıf olduğunu düşünün
basitleştirilmiş haliyle
demiştim
class o stream
tabi neden basitleştirilmiş
hali diyorum
çünkü o stream
aslında bir
sınıf şaplonu
yani template parametreleri var
demiştim ki
bunlar
o stream sınıfının
operatör
left chip fonksiyonları
ve overload edilmişler
yani
örneğin
inti yazdıran bu
double yazdıran bu
longu yazdıran bu
diğerlerini yazmıyorum
fakat
bir de şöyle
operatör left chip fonksiyonu var
parametresi
function pointer olan
yani
geri dönüş değeri
o stream ref
olan
bir
function pointer
parametreye sahip
öyle ki
adresini istediği
fonksiyonun
parametreste
o stream ref
olmalı
arkadaşlar
bu fonksiyonun
kodu şöyle yazılmış
aslında
adresini aldığı
fonksiyonu
çağırıyor
ona argüman olarak
yıldız disi
gönderiyor
ve
çağırdığı fonksiyonun
geri dönüş değerinde
referans semantiğiyle
döndürüyor
yani
bu ne demek
örneğin
siz
stia out
intl'e yazdığınızda
aslında
bu fonksiyonun
çağrılmasını
sağlıyorsunuz
intl'e bir fonksiyon
jenerik bir fonksiyon
bu fonksiyona
yani
burada gösterdiğim fonksiyona
intl'e fonksiyonunun
adresiyle çağrı yapmış
oluyorsunuz
burada tabi ki
function to pointer
conversion oluyor
böyle yazmakta
şöyle yazmak
arasında fark yok
dolayısıyla
burada çağrılan
fonksiyon
en alttaki fonksiyon
çağrısı için
aslında ne oluyor
intl'e fonksiyonuna
cout'u göndermiş
oluyorsunuz
yani siz
stia out
intl'e yaparak
bu fonksiyonu
çağırdınız
ama bu fonksiyonda
bu çağrıyı
neye dönüştürdü
tam tersi
intl'e fonksiyonuna
stia out'u
argüman olarak
gönderdiniz
arkadaşlar
şimdi geleceğiz
hayır bu yüzden değil
intl'e'nin
kodunun
şöyle olduğunu
düşünün
neden
intl'e tercih edilmiyor
intl'e şöyle bir fonksiyon
o stream rep
tabi normalde
intl'e de
template
intl
yani
intline
arkadaşlar
o stream
rep
adresini yukarıdaki
fonksiyona
gönderdik ya
bu intl
fonksiyonu ne yapıyor
son derece
basit
arkadaşlar
önce
akıma
bir newline
veriyor
sonra da
stream'e
flash ediyor
os
flash
return
os
şimdi
intl'e'nin
tercih edilmemesinin
nedeni
aslında
burada
fonksiyon çağrı
maliyeti
olması falan
değil
onlar inline
zaten derleyici
onları optimize
ediyor
rasul
tahmin edin
tercih edilmemesinin
nedeni
kimse ödeyecek
ekrana bakarak
tahmin edin
flash
bravo rasul
flash ne
demek
arkadaşlar
buffer'ı
flash ediyor
yani o stream'in
buffer'ını
flash etmesi
demek
başka bir event
beklemeden
bravo
diske yazma
yani yazma
maliyeti
device'e yazma
oysa
oysa bu
flash işlemi
için
ya
bizim
programcının
doğrudan
flash
fonksiyonuna
çağrı
yapması
ya da
o buffer'ın
dolması
ya da
programın
normal
terminate
etmesi
ya da
hepsini
ileride
göreceğiz
see out
see in
high edildiği
için
bir giriş
işleminin
yapılması
gerekiyor
dolayısıyla
örneğin
tek bir
karakterden
sonra
karakter
yazdırıyorsunuz
gidip de
entlay'i
çağırırsanız
boş yere
flash maliyetini
taşımış olursunuz
o flash maliyeti
de ciddi
o yüzden
entlay'i
hiç kullanmayın
demiyorum
arkadaşlar
ama
gereksiz yere
kullanmayın
mülakatlarda
da en son
en çok
sorulan
sorulardan
biridir
şimdi
entlay'in
hikayesi
bu
ama
bakın
entlay'le
yetinmek
zorunda
değiliz ki
ben şöyle
bir fonksiyon
yazsaydım
stut
ostrim
ref
arkadaşlar
espriye
bakın
şimdi
left
stut
ostrim
ref
os
arkadaşlar
set
f
ios
stud
left
ios
adjust
filter
return
os
takip edebiliyor muyuz
şimdi
söyleyin bakalım
mesela
ben şöyle bir kod
yazar isem
see out
left
arkadaşlar
burada
çağrılan
fonksiyon
aslında
left
fonksiyonu
olacak
left
de see out
argümanı
olarak gönderecek
ben de
see out'un
format state'ini
left olarak
değiştirmiş olacağım
işte
şimdiye kadar
gördüğümüz
bütün formatlama
özellikleri için
bu şekilde
yazılmış
bir
ne var
austrian
manipülatörü
var
arkadaşlar
böyle
austrian
manipülatörlerinin
olması
işimizi
kolaylaştırıyor
belki çok
kolaylaştırmıyor
çünkü çok daha
iyisi var
format kütüphanesi
ama bir
aynı kolaylaştırıyor
mesela bir örnek
daha verelim
buğul alfa
aslında
şöyle bir
fonksiyon
ben
ilk harfini
büyük yazıyorum
ki
orijinaliyle
karışmasın
diye
ayos'un
arkadaşlar
set f
ayos'un
buğul alfası
dikkat ederseniz
aslında
fonksiyonun
ismi
o
bayrağı
set etmek için
kullanılan
maskenin
ismiyle
aynı
önce akılda
tutmak kolay oluyor
ama
kaan can
rasul
emirhan
bir şey
daha var
peki eski haline
nasıl getireceğim
eski haline
getirmek için de
anset f
fonksiyonunu
çağırmıyor muydum
o zaman
bir manipülatör de
onun için olsa
arkadaşlar
onun ismi de
no
boğul alfa
olsa
no
boğul alfa da
anset f
yi çağırsa
mesela
onluk sayı
sistemi
on altılık sayı
sekizlik sayı
sistemi
bunlara
geçiş için
bir tanesini
yazalım
sadece
ismi
hex olan
bir manipülatör
olsa
ve
aslında bu
set f
fonksiyonunu
ios'un
hex'i
ve ios'un
base field'i
ile çağırsa
herkes burayı anladı mı
işte
görüp görebileceğiniz
bütün
arkadaşlar
formatlama
özellikleri için
böyle
manipülatörler var
mesela
o zaman
ben
bir kere de
şöyle bir kod
yazabilirim
izleyin
see out
hex
arkadaşlar
buğul alfa
uppercase
hadi buğul alfayı
şimdi
karıştırmayalım
uppercase
showbase
hatta
doğrudan
gördünüz
değil mi
aslında
hex
fonksiyonunu
çağırdım
sonra
uppercase
fonksiyonunu
çağırdım
sonra
showbase
fonksiyonunu
çağırdım
ve bu fonksiyonların
hepsine
aslında
neyi
geçmiş oldum
arkadaşlar
see out
nesnesini
yani böyle yazmakta
aslında ne aynı anlamda
hex fonksiyonunu
çağır
ona
see out'ı
gönder
bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
yine
see out
uppercase
fonksiyonuna
bunu gönder
showbase
fonksiyonuna
bunu gönder
rasul
anladık mı
burayı
en son
sorduğunuz
soru
biraz uzun
bir cevabı
hak ettiğinden
rasul
yazarak
cevap
vermedim
bir ara
onu anlatacağım
oldu mu
exception'le
ilgili
sorduğunuz
bir soru
vardı
burayı
herkes
anladı
mı
evet
arkadaşlar
modern
c++'da
şu maskeler
daha önce
şu manipülatörler
vardı
mesela
bakın
see out
fixed
evet
izleyin
ve
bir boşluk
scientific
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
o stream manipülatörü
kullanmanın
avantajı
bakın
chaining'i
bozmadan
tek bir
statement'la
hem
fixed
notasyonda
hem de
scientific
notasyonda
yazdırdım
burada
modern
c++'la
birlikte
hani
hem fixed
hem scientific
iki site set edildiğinde
yazma
formatlaması
nasıl oluyordu
iki site set edildiğinde
yazma
formatlaması
nasıl oluyordu
arkadaşlar
cevap
hex
bravo
işte onun içinde
hex float
isimli bir manipülatör
eklediler
yani örneğin
burada
hatta onu da
ekleyelim
arkadaşlar
new line
hex float
ve
yine
aynı değer
small stream
manipülatörlerinin
denen yapısını
anladık
değil mi
arkadaşlar
bu şöyle bir
imkanı da
veriyor
diyelim ki
bir projede
özel bir
formatlama
yapısına
ihtiyacınız var
o zaman
onu da
kendi
manipülatörünüz
yapabilirsiniz
mesela
diyelim ki
arkadaşlar
rasulün
rası
tabi isim böyle
olmayacak
normalde
fm
ras fm
rasulün
formatlaması
stud
ostrim
ref
stud
ostrim
ref
os
mesela
istesin ki
arkadaşlar
hatta burada
fonksiyon
kendisine
çağrın
set f
stud
ios'un
show
base'i
mixer
veya
stud
ios'un
uppercase'i
bir sürü
formatlama
kendi tercihine
göre böyle
yapmış olsun
mesela
os
precision
diyelim ki
arkadaşlar
başka
os
set f
stud
ios'un
u
arkası
hatta
default'a
döndürmek
için
ayrı bir
ne de
yazabilir
arkadaşlar
bir
ostrim
manipülatörü
yazabilir
şimdi
artık
kendi
formatlama
moduna
geçmek
için
örneğin
cout
arkadaşlar
doğrudan
rast
pm'yi
bu şekilde
kullanabilir
böylece
artık
istediği
bütün
formatlama
özellikleri
ne yapılmış
olacak
arkadaşlar
set edilmiş
olacak
buraya
kadar
anladık
mı
arkadaşlar
şimdi
şimdiye
kadar
verdiğim
formatlama
özelliklerinde
hep
o stream
sınıfından
bahsettim
ama
iStream
sınıfı
için de
manipülatörlerin
özelliklerim
formatlama
özelliklerinin
bir kısmını
set edebiliyorsunuz
get edebiliyorsunuz
yani
aynı
ya da benzer
formatlama
özellikleri
iStream
sınıfı
için de
geçerli
arkadaşlar
iStream
sınıfı
için de
örnek vereceğim
ve nasıl
o stream
manipülatörleri
varsa
iStream
manipülatörleri
de var
bir örnek
verelim
mesela
iStream
için
bir manipülatör
kullanalım
sayı sistemi
arkadaşlar
şimdi örneği
dikkatli takip edin
int x
ve
x eşittir
şimdi
bakın
stout
bir sayı
giriniz
c in
x
şu anda
deck modunda
dolayısıyla
girişi
onluk sayı
sistemi
olarak
alıyor
ama
şimdi
bakın
c in
set f
ios'un
arkadaşlar
hex'i
ios'un
base
field'i
şimdi
artık
16'lık
sayı
sisteminde
olacak
ve x'in
değerini
yazdıralım
c in
önce girişi
yapalım
c in
x
bir sayı
giriniz
arkadaşlar
4 kere
değil mi
evet
dd
hatta
sayı sistemi
tabanını da
detekt edecek
0x
1ac4
görüyor musunuz
evet
arkadaşlar
birkaç örnek daha
ama tabi
böyle yazmak yerine
burada da yine
manipülatör var
yalnız dikkat edin
tabi bunlar
iStream manipülatörü
olduğu için
bu sefer
operator
right
shift'i
kullanacaksınız
mesela
bakınız
x'i
hexadecimal
sayı
sisteminde
y'yi
oktay
sayı
sisteminde
z'yi
ise
decimal
sayı
sisteminde
set etmek
istiyorum
3 sayı
giriniz
yani
girişleri
böyle
alacağım
hex x
arkadaşlar
efendim
okt
y
dek
z
x'in değeri
y'nin değeri
ve
z'nin değeri
3 sayı
giriniz
hatta
hepsinde
aynı
basamakları
kullanalım
bu
çünkü
hex
bu
oktay
yani
artı
bu
decimal
espriyi
anladınız mı
yine
başka bir
örnek
bakınız
yani
giriş
kısmında
da manipülatör
olacağını
ya da
giriş
kısmında
da
formatlama
özelliklerinin
etkin
olduğunu
göstermek
için
izleyiniz
charge
str
arkadaşlar
siyahat
bir yazı
girin
ya da
bir isim
girin
sin
str
siyahat
isim
özellikle köşeli parantez içine yazdırıyorum
str
bir isim girin
alihan
abdul
mutalip
arkadaşlar
burada
girişi yaparken
tamamen
hatta
debug modunda
çalıştırayım
bakınız
tanımsız
davranış
bir işte
herhangi bir şekilde
dizinin boyutunu
tespit etme şansı
necati doğru çalışıyor
demeyin
arkadaşlar
o tanımsız
davranışın
görüntüsü
sizi tatmin etmek
zorunda değil
ama bakın
sin
arkadaşlar
set ve
ayu manipüle
başlık dosyası
tıpkı
çıkış işleminde
olduğu gibi
set ve
birazdan bunları da
göreceğiz
örneğin
str
daha önce
belki
set ve'yi
o stream
manipülatörü
olarak
kullanmıştık
şimdi
i stream
manipülatörü
olarak
kullanıyoruz
bir isim girin
obdül
canbaz
gördüğünüz gibi
4 karakteri aldı
5. karakteri
olarak
nav karakteri
aldı
arkadaşlar
şimdi
biraz bizi zorlayacak
bir konu daha var
bu da
parametreli
manipülatörler
şimdi
set ve
width fonksiyonuna
mı çağrı yapıyor
kesinlikle
birazdan göreceğiz
onu
arkadaşlar
burada dikkat ederseniz
set ve
bir manipülatör
fakat
diğer manipülatörlerden
farklı olarak
bir argüman
alıyor
işte böyle
manipülatörlere
ister
o stream
manipülator
ister
i stream
manipülator
olsun
o stream
arkadaşlar
parametreli
manipülatör
deniyor
mesela
parametreli
manipülatörlere
örnekler
verelim ama
hemen şunu
söyleyelim
standart
olanlar
iomanic
başlık
dosyasında
yani
set ve
oradaki
set
w'daki
w
width'den
kısaltma
arkadaşlar
set v
ve diğer
parametreli
manipülatörler
standart
olanlar
iomanic
başlık
dosyasında
mesela birkaç örnek
parametreli
manipülatörleri
izleyin
int x
eşit bir
5.431
stu
string
str
alihan
şimdi
bakın
cout
left
set
set v
x
arkadaşlar
ama ondan önce
set fill
aliyans
sorunasına cevap
evet set v
width fonksiyonuna
çağrı yapıyor
set fill de
fill fonksiyonuna
çağrı yapıyor
set fill
mesela
ne olsun
yıldız
x
bir tane de
double değer
olsun
ondan sonra
str'yi yazdırsın
şimdilik
bu kadar
bakın
buradaki
gerek set v
gerek set fill
bunlar
parametreli
manipülatörler
set v
width'i set ediyor
set fill de
fill karakterini
set ediyor
gördünüz değil mi
sola dayalı olarak
yazdı
set v
fonksiyonuyla
yazma alanın
genişliğini
16 karakteri
set etmiş oldum
ve doldurma karakteri
space yerine
set fill fonksiyonuna
yapılan
çağrıyla
arkadaşlar
yıldız oldu
yine şöyle de
yazabilirdim
see out
mesela
precision fonksiyonunu
çağırmak yerine
set precision
takip edebiliyor muyuz
bunlar
parametreli
manipülatörler
arkadaşlar
şimdi
parametreli
manipülatörler
mülakatlarda
gelen
biraz
zorlayıcı
sorulardan biri
parametreli
manipülatör
yazmanız
parametreli
manipülatör
yazmanın
birden fazla
yolu
olabilir
şimdi
burayı
çok çok
dikkatli
izlemenizi
istiyorum
birlikte
parametreli
manipülatör
yazacağız
arkadaşlar
parametresiz
manipülatör
yazmak
çok kolay
zaten
bayağı bir
örnek verdik
değil mi
ama şimdi
parametreli
manipülatörü
nasıl yazacağız
burayı
çok çok
dikkatli
izleyin
çünkü
kafanız
karışabilir
mesela
diyelim ki
ben şöyle bir
o stream
parametreli
manipülatörü
yazmak
istiyorum
Siyah
Arkadaşlar
NS
Ali
Veli
Buradaki
NS
öyle bir
parametreli
manipülatör
olacak ki
aldığı
argüman
ne ise
o kadar
boşluk karakteri
space
karakteri
basacak
yani
örneğin
burada
hatta bir tane daha
yazalım
23 sayısını
yazdıktan sonra
12 karakter
boşluk
verecek
Ali yazısını
yazdıktan sonra
5 karakter
boşluk
verecek
takip edebildik mi
buraya kadar
evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi
bunun nasıl
yapılabileceğini
birlikte
düşünelim
böyle bir
fonksiyon
yok
yani
o stream
sınıfının
o
operator
left
chip
fonksiyonu
arkadaşlar
parametresi
o stream
olan
bir ne
istiyor
fonksiyon
dolayısıyla
NS'nin
böyle bir
fonksiyon
olma
ihtimali
yok
ama
bakın
çok basit
şöyle bir
hile
yapabiliriz
çok dikkatli
izleyin
aslında
NS
bir sınıfın
ismi olsa
lütfen
anladığınızdan
emin olun
Deniz
Emirhan
Kağan
Mutlu
Muhammed
anlamazsanız
bir daha
açıklayacağım
NS
bir sınıf
olsa
bu durumda
bu ifade
ne anlama
gelir
NS
ismi
aileni
fayrı
bir sınıf
olsa
bu ifade
ne anlama
gelir
o sınıf
türünden
bir
temporali
objekt
oluşturmuş
olurum
değil mi
burayı
takip
edebildik
mi
o sınıf
türünden
bir
temporali
objekt
oluşturmuş
olurum
evet
ama
arkadaşlar
izleyin
bu durumda
eğer
NS
bir sınıfsa
değerini
argüman
olarak
alıp
yani
int
parametreli
bir
konstruktörü
varsa
ne yapmış
olurum
arkadaşlar
bir
NS
nesnesini
bir
PR value
expression
olarak
oluşturmuş
olurum
peki
o zamanda
operatör
left shift'i
overload
edemiyor muyum
bu
NS
sınıfı
için
operatörü
overload
etsem
bu da
bu işlemi
yapabilir
değil mi
herkes
anladı mı
evet
hadi bakalım
bunu yapalım
necat şöyle
değil mi
class
NS
evet
bu bir
struct
olabilir
peki ne
yapacağım
bu sınıfa
bir
konstruktör koyacağım
NS
int
diyelim ki
n
sınıfa bir de
veri elemanı
koyacağım
private
int
enval
ve
n
bakın hala
syntax hatası
neden
e çünkü
böyle bir overload
yok
ama o da
kolay
friend
hidden friend
yapıyorum
stu
o stream
referans
arkadaşlar
operator
left shift
stu
o stream
referans
o s
ve
konus
ns
ref
x
işte
şimdi bakın
yardımcı araç
hata işaretlemekten
vazgeçti
neden
e çünkü bu fonksiyona
çağrı yapacak
derleyici
buraya kadar
herkes anladı mı
mehmet çan bey
nazım bey
ozan bey
evet
e o zaman
sadece ve sadece
yaz yapmam
gereken
os
streamine
ns
x'in
arkadaşlar
envali kadar
ne vermem
gerekiyor
space karakteri
vermem
gerekiyor
tabi
şu anda
elemanı
public
değil de
private
yaptığım
için
int
get
while
fonksiyon isimlerine
bakmayınız
çünkü
iyi isim için
zamana ihtiyacım var
evet
ben şimdi
Almanya'ya ilk
gittiğimde
iş için
yıllar yıllar önce
bir yerde bira içeyim
dedim
bira söyle dedim
bekliyorum
gelmiyor
ondan sonra
derler ya
bizim bira nerede
kaldı falan diye
klasik şöyle bir şey
söylüyorlar
ben tabi
Almancasını söylemeyeceğim
iyi bir biranın
biraz zamana
ihtiyacı var
yani hemen öyle
beklemeyeceksin
iyi bira istiyorsan
biraz beklemen
gerekiyor
burada da iyi isim için
biraz zamana
ihtiyacımız var
o kadar da
zamanımız olmadığı için
burada
fonksiyon isimlerinin
ya da değişken isimlerinin
biraz
kötü olmasına
aldırmayacaksınız
ama üretimde
böyle yapmam
oturup bir kahve içip
değişkenime
güzel bir isim
düşünürüm
biraz abartılı bir şekilde
bu isimlerin
önemini anlatmak için
şöyle diyorlar
değil mi
doğacak ilk çocuğunuza
isim verirken
ne kadar
özen gösteriyorsanız
değişkenlerinizin
isimleri için de
o kadar özen gösterin
bu biraz abartılı
evet
most
return
arkadaşlar
ne olacak
env
tamam
şimdi artık
fonksiyonu
yazabiliriz
bu arada
fonksiyonu
friend yaptığım için
böyle bir get
fonksiyonuna
ihtiyacım yok
çünkü
friend
ama
friend olmasaydı
private olduğu için
get fonksiyonu
yazacaktım
o zaman
for
int i eşit 0
i küçük
x'in
envoli
friend olduğu için
erişebiliyorum
artı artı i
efendim
os
put
ve
space
işte bu kadar
isterseniz
deneyelim
ama
bir eksiğimiz kaldı
return
os
öyle değil mi
geri dönüş değeri
o stream
nesnesinin
kendisi
olacak
buraya kadar
kodu anlamayan
var mı
parametreli bir manipülatörün
yazım tekniklerinden
biri
bu olabilir
değil mi
şurayı da düzeltelim
ve bir şey daha
ekleyelim
ns
alihan
neco
yerliyorum
evet bakın
gerçekten de
burada return value
optimization
oluyor mu
nerede
return value
optimization
oluyor mu
burada
return value
optimization
için bir konu yok
çünkü
fonksiyonun
parametresi
referans
zaten referans
semantik
kullanılıyor
return value
optimization
otomatik ömürlü
or yazdığımız yerde
diyor arkadaşım
tam anlamaya çalışayım
burada mı
OS zaten
referans
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri de
referans
dolayısıyla
burada
return value
optimization
bahsetme
doğru değil
return value
optimization
olması için
arkadaşlar
geri dönüş
değerinin
otomatik ömürlü
bir nesne
olması gerekiyor
mandatory
copy
illusion
olması için
bu sefer
return ifadesinin
PR value
expression
olması
gerek
peki
parametreli
manipülatör
kısmını
anladık mı
anlamayan var mı
evet
arkadaşlar
geçen yine bir
arkadaşım
C++
mülakatına
girmiş
iki tane
basit soru
sormuşlar
ama
ikisine de
doğru cevap
vermiş
biri
bunun
new line
mısını
sormuşlar
yani
space
değil de
new line
verecek
o yüzden
ona cevap
vermiyorum
diğer soruda
şunu sormuşlar
aslında çok
basit bir
soru
bu ifadenin
türü
ve değeri
nedir
diye
sormuşlar
herhalde
bizim sınıfta
buna yanlış
cevap verecek
kimse çıkmaz
bir de
bunu zor
soru
diye
sormuş
mülakat
yapan
cevap
tabi ki
integral
promotion
nedeniyle
bunlar
bu
in olmasına
rağmen
int'e
dönüşümü
olur
dolayısıyla
bu ifadenin
türü
int'dir
değeri de
birdir
aslında
soruyu
daha çok
şöyle
soruyorlar
true
artı
ifadenin
türü
int
değeri
true
ile
topladığımda
cevabını
alıyorum
anlaşıldı mı
evet
peki
parametreli
manipülatörlerden
bahsettik
arkadaşlar
tabi
iStream
sınıfı
için de
parametreli
manipülatör
yazabilirsiniz
yani
sadece
o stream
sınıfı
için
değil
arkadaşlar
şimdi
lütfen dikkat
önemli bir
sorundan
daha bahsedeceğiz
şimdi bu
üretimde de
buna pek
dikkat etmiyorlar
aslında çok
tehlikeli bir
durum
arkadaşlar
diyelim ki
ben
bir fonksiyon
yazıyorum
void
funk
bunu çok
görüyorum
yani fonksiyon
neyle ilgili
olduğu
önemli değil
şurada
using
bildirimi
yapalım
text
show
base
uppercase
diyelim ki
burada bir
değer
yazdırıyor
fonksiyonun kodu
bu kadar
değil
fonksiyonun içinde
bir
yer
örneğin
burada bir
kod var
hemen
bakar
bakmaz
burada
yanlış olan
ne
bana söyleyebilir
misiniz
funk
dışarıya
açık
external
bir
fonksiyon
belki bu
hatayı
siz de
yazdığınız
kodlarda
yapıyor
olabilirsiniz
o yüzden
lütfen
düşünerek
cevap
vermeye
çalışın
burada
problem
ne
bu
arada bu
son
kod
yani
fonksiyonda
bundan sonra
başka bir
kod
yok
peki
o zaman şu
soruya
cevap
verin
ama
size
karşı
kaba
olmak
istemiyorum
deyim
olarak
kabul edin
siyah alt
babanızın
malı mı
öyle bir
tür
sözler
arkadaşlar
alınmaz
Azeri
Türkçesinde
de var
bilmiyorum
ama
öyle de
derler
babanın
malı mı
siyah alt
babanızın
malı mı
değil
şakanın
nerede
olduğunu
anladınız mı
arkadaşlar
siyah alt
sizin
değil ki
herkes
kullanıyor
onu
siyah alt
global bir
değişken
değil mi
e ne
yani
şimdi bu
fonksiyon
çağrıldıktan
sonra
siz
siyah alt
nesnesinin
format
state'ini
tamamen
değiştirmiş
oldunuz
değil mi
yani
bu fonksiyon
çağrıldıktan
sonra
örneğin
başka bir
fonksiyon
çağrıldığında
üçüncü
parti
kütüphanede
o da siyah alt
nesnesini
kullanırsak
evet
Oğuzhan Bey'in
dediği gibi
tüm kod etkilenecek
bundan
o yüzden
bu şekilde
sorumsuz
hareket etmemelisiniz
arkadaşlar
şimdi
buradaki
problemi
çözmenin
yolu basit
derler ya
nasıl almışsan
öyle bırak
bu da
halk arasında
böyle
mekanlarda
yazılan
tipik
tabelalardan
biridir
değil mi
nasıl
aldıysan
öyle bırak
o zaman
bizde
siyah alt
nesnesini
ne yapmalıyız
değerli arkadaşlar
nasıl aldıysak
öyle bırakmalıyız
peki bunu
nasıl yapacağız
o
bunu yapmanın
birden fazla
yolu var
ama
bu tür
kodlara
bunu
yapan
rayi
idiomunu
kullanarak
resource
acquisition
is
initialization
bu tür
yapıları
sağlayan
idiomlara
genelde
guard
gidiyor
onları
deniyor
bu da
formatlamayı
koruduğu için
o zaman
burada da
format
guard
diyelim
arkadaşlar
son derece
basit
izleyin
o zaman
koda girişte
o stream
nesnesinin
formatlama
özelliklerini
bir şekilde
saklayacaksınız
koddan çıkışta da
formatlama
özelliklerini
eski
state'e
geri getireceksiniz
bunun için
eğer
üçüncü
parti bir
kütüphane
kullanmıyorsanız
basit bir
sınıf
yazabilirsiniz
mesela
class
arkadaşlar
fmt
guard
ya da bitişik
de olabilir
class
format
guard
evet
format
guard
ne yapacak
bir
o stream
nesnesine
referans
semantiğiyle
edinecek
çok zevkli
böyle kodlar
stud
o stream
ref
arkadaşlar
ne diyelim
m
os
ama
yine sınıfın
veri elemanlarında
diğer
değerleri
tutacak
mesela
arkadaşlar
m
tut
yani örnek olarak
şöyle yapalım
elemanlar
neler olsun
mesela
ios
base'in
tabii
namespace
tut
ios
base'in
ya da
ios'un
pmt
flex
m
başka
stud
ios'un
arkadaşlar
stream
size'ı
türünden
stream
size'ın
kendisi de
arkadaşlar
ama bu
ios'un değil
bu
doğrudan
namespace'ın
stud
stream
size
türünden
m
width
arkadaşlar
şimdi burada
ilgili türü
hatırlayamıyorsanız
şöyle
yazabilirsiniz
bakın
declet
type'in
kullanıldığı
yerlerden
örnekler
diyelim ki
fmt
flex
türünü
ya da
width'in
türünü
ya da
fill'in
türünü
hatırlamıyorsunuz
o zaman
şöyle
yazın
fmt
flex'i
gt'den
fonksiyonun
ismi
neydi
flex
o zaman
declet
type
arkadaşlar
os
mos
flex
ismi
anladınız mı
decletype'la
tür elde
etmiyor
muyum
o zaman
decletype
emas
flex
türünden
m
flex
decletype
tabi ki
decletype'ın
operanda olan
ifade için
unevaluated
context
geçerliydi
em
width
tabi hangilerini
değiştireceksiniz
precision
em
feel
o zaman
bir tane
constructor
koyuyorum
pmt
guard
stud
o stream
ref
stud
o stream
ref
os
em
arkadaşlar
os
em
flex
os
em
width
os
in
width
ne kaldı
em
fill
eksik olanları
siz
tamamlarsınız
fill
fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değeri
ve
m
precision
o
os'in
precision
değeri
bu da
fonksiyonun
ana bloğu
takip
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
studio stream
referans
şurada
eksik bir şey
kaldı mı
precision'dan
sonra
bir parantez
burada
sanıyorum
eksik bir şey
kalmadı
teşekkür ederim
resul
buraya
kadar
bir yine de
derleyelim
evet
arkadaşlar
ama
tahmin ediyorsunuz
değil mi
bundan sonrasını
kim söyleyecek
rayi
idiomu
dediğime göre
rayi
idiomu
dediğime göre
arkadaşlar
evet
bir tane
destraktır
bravo
alihan
tabi ki
destraktır
pmt
guard
sınıfın
destraktırı
mos
flex
biliyorsunuz
msetmget
fonksiyonuydu
m
flex
mos
with
fonksiyonu
m
width
fill
fonksiyonu
m
neydi ismi
fill
ve
precision
fonksiyonu
m
precision
işte bu kadar
arkadaşlar
kullandığı yere
bakalım
mesela
diyelim ki
void
punk
int
x
tmt
guard
kınık
ismi
bitişikmiş
pmt
guard
my guard
arkadaşlar
stud
see out
ve
diyelim ki
stud
see out
hex
uppercase
show
bass
x
şimdi bakın
main fonksiyonu
punk
476 bin
4 milyon
761 bin
ama
punk'ı
çağırdıktan
sonra
stud
see out
efendim
formatlama
özelliklerine
geri dönmüş
olacak
eğer
geri dönmemiş
olsaydı
76'yı da
0x
hexade
ismarsay
sisteminde
yazacak
olurdu
değil mi
burayı
anladık mı
anlamadığımız
bir şey
var mı
evet
ama arkadaşlar
aslında bir yol
daha var
henüz
görmediğimiz bir yol
daha var
arkadaşlar bakın stream nesnelerinin
benim şimdiye kadar size göstermediğim
aslında biraz daha ileride göstermem gerekiyor
bir fonksiyonu var
fonksiyona bakın
readbot
arkadaşlar readbuff fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş değerinin
türünü görüyor musunuz
streambuff
pointer'ı
ben
stream konusunu
streams konusunu
ilk anlatmaya
başladığımda
hani sınıfları
göstermiştim
ve şöyle bir şey
söylemiştim
kalıtım
yererjisini
göstermiştim
demiştim ki
aslında
gerçekte
okuma yazma
işlemlerinin
yapılması
arka planda
o buffer'ı
kontrol eden
stream'in buffer'ını
kontrol eden nesne
tarafından yapılıyor
işte bak o sınıfın ismi
streambuff
yani streambuffer'dan
kısaltma
gördüğünüz gibi
readbuff fonksiyonu
aslında bize ne döndürüyor
bir streambuff
pointer'ı döndürüyor
ve o stream sınıfının
bir konstruktör'ı var
stud
o stream
bu konstruktör
şimdi gelecek karşınızda
gördüğünüz gibi
streambuff türünden
pointer parametreye sahip
yani bu şu demek
ben
seaout nasıl bir
o stream nesnesi ise
arkadaşlar
seaout nesnesi gibi
bir o stream
nesnesini
oluşturmak için
bir streambuff
pointer'ı
kullanabilirim
hangi streambuff
pointer'ını
kullanırsam
o pointer'ın
gösterdiği
buffer'ı
kullanacak
yani
Necati
şöyle mi
yazacağız
izleyin
çok eğlenceli
o stream
my seaout
seaout
readbuff
şimdi bakın
hem
benim
my seaout
dediğim nesne
yani
ismine
my seaout
dediğim
ismini
my seaout
olarak belirlediğim
değişken
hem de
global seaout
nesnesi
aynı buffer'ı
kullanıyor
yani
şimdi
ister
my seaout'ı
kullanarak
formatlı bir çıkış
yapın
Alihan
ister seaout'ı
aynı buffer'a
yazacak
buraya kadar
anladık mı
peki
tahmin edin
bundan sonra
Necati
ne söyleyecek
yanıt
o stream
stream nesnelerinin
buffer'ı
aynı olabilir
ama
format state'i
her nesnenin
kendi state'i
yani
ben
örneğin
my seaout
nesnesinin
format state'ini
değiştirdiğim zaman
seaout nesnesinin
format state'ini
değiştirmiş
olur muyum
cevap
hayır
tahmin ettiğiniz gibi
o zaman
bakınız
my seaout
örnek kolay olsun
diye
hex
showbiz
uppercase
pool alfa
ve
my seaout
arkadaşlar
büyüktür
ama
alt'a
bakın
seaout
derleyip
çalıştırıyorum
gördünüz mü
ikisi de
standart
output'a
yazdı
çünkü
aynı buffer'ı
kullanıyor
ama
yukarıdaki
my seaout
nesnesiyle
yaptığım
çıkışta
hexadezmal
sayı sisteminde
sayı sistemi
tabanını
gösterdi
harf karakterlerine
büyük yazdı
ve
boolean
değeri
true false
olarak yazdı
ama
diğerinde
default
formatlama
özellikleri
kullanıldı
anlaşıldı
mı
evet
arkadaşlar
bir fonksiyondan
daha bahsetmek
istiyorum
ondan sonra
konuyu
değiştireceğim
ve
bu seferde
akımın
benim tabirimle
sağlık durumu
condition state'e
geçeceğiz
Alihan
Bozkır
az önceki fonksiyon
içinde
my seaout
oluştursaydık
format kart
kılasına
gerek kalmazdı
değil mi
evet
yani bu
tabi iki yol
birbirinin tam alternatifi
değil
ama sorunuzun
net cevabı
evet
o yüzden ben
iki ayrı
yolu da
göstermiş oldum
evet
arkadaşlar
izleyin
demin şöyle bir şey
söyledim
dedim ki
iStream sınıfı
içinde
manipülatörler var
işte örnek verdik
örneğin
setv manipülatörü
hex manipülatörü
onlar
iStream sınıfı için
kullanabileceğimiz
manipülatörlere
örnekler
arkadaşlar
iStream sınıfının da
bazı
yine
üye fonksiyonlar var
bakın şimdi
üye fonksiyonlardan
henüz bahsetmedik
ama
şimdiye kadar
bazı örneklerde
kullandığım
sınıfların
bazı
üye fonksiyonlarına
örnek vereceğim
bir
arkadaşlar
get line isimli
global fonksiyon
çok önemli
dosya işlemlerinde de
bakın
normalde
giriş
formatta giriş
yapılırken
boşluk karakterleri
atlanıyor
ingilizcesiyle
skip
ediliyor
dolayısıyla
boşluklar
içeren bir yazıyı
doğrudan
bir stream'e
okumanız
bir string'e
mümkün değil
bir stream'den
bir string'e
okumanız
mümkün değil
yani şöyle bir
kod yazarsanız
string
name
see out
isminizi
giriniz
see in
name
arkadaşlar
see out
isminiz
name
şimdi bakın programın
çıkışına
runtime'ını
isminizi
giriniz
Haldun
isminiz
ama şimdi bakın
isminizi
girin
Ömer
Faruk
Aksoy
isminiz
Ömer
çünkü
whitespace
karakterler
separatör
olarak alındı
dolayısıyla
bu durumda
bizim
girişte
boşluk
karakterlerinde
alabileceğimiz
bir yol
olması lazım
işte
ismi
get line
olan fonksiyonlarla
bunu yapabiliyorsunuz
get line
fonksiyonları
global fonksiyon
şimdi şuraya
kaldırdım
get line
birinci parametresi
arkadaşlar
stream
nesnesi
stud
scene
ikinci parametresi
tabi her ikisi de
referans
semantiyeli
alınıyor
string
nesnesi
yani
bu şekilde
fonksiyonu
çağırdığımızda
get line
fonksiyonunu
bu şekilde
çağırdığımızda
ne oluyor
bu
iStream
nesnesini
kullanarak
onu
stream
nesnesi
kullanarak
oradan
arkadaşlar
bu
string
değişkenine
girişi
alıyor
geçen de
derste
burada
get line
için
böyle bir
uyarı
vermişti
bizim
başlık
dosyalarımızla
ilgili mi
demiştik
bir dakika
string'i dahil
etmemişim
tabi
buradaki
atanın
nedeni
o
evet
tamam
string
başlık
dosyasını
inklod etmediğim
için
şimdi bakın
Ömer
Faruk
Aksoy
gördüğünüz gibi
boşlukları da
aldı
hatta
buradaki
get line
fonksiyonunun
aslında
üçüncü bir
parametresi
daha var
izleyin
get line
tamam
şimdi geldi
bakınız
bir şey
dikkatinizi
çekecek mi
arkadaşlar
tabi çok
over
road
olduğu için
şuradan
göstermem
gerekiyor
evet
arkadaşlar
dikkat ederseniz
fonksiyonun
birinci
bir parametresi
daha var
delimiter
aslında
bu parametre
default
argüman
olarak
arkadaşlar
new line
alıyor
ama şimdi
şöyle yazarsanız
örneğin
get line
c in
name
nokta
bu sefer
neyi alacak
delimiter olarak
nokta karakterini
alacak
özellikle dosyadan
okuma işlemlerinde
bu çok önemli
kazanacak
isminize girin
ahmet
faruk
aydın
arkadaşlar
gördünüz değil mi
artık
delimiter olarak
nokta karakterini
aldı
yani noktaya kadar
olanları okudu
oraya anladık mı
evet
demek ki
girişte
get line
fonksiyonunu
kullanarak
ben
boşluk karakterleri
dahil
ya da belirli bir
delimiter'e
gelene kadar
olan karakterleri
bir string
nesnesine
ya da bir
char diziye
alabiliyorum
arkadaşlar
iki
buraya dikkat
arkadaşlar
bazı durumlarda
bizim
standart
giriş
bakımından
yani input
stream'de
karakterleri
ekstrakt edip
fakat
kullanmamamız
gerekiyor
yani tek
amacımız
karakterleri
nereden
çıkarmak
stream'den
bu neden
çok önemli
c'de de
bu konuyu
anlatmıştım
arkadaşlar bakın
mesela şöyle bir
kod olsa
int x
see out
bir sayı
giriniz
see in
x
see out
bir sayı
daha
giriniz
see in
x
sorusundan sonra
dikkat takip edin
x eşittir
ve x eşittir
arkadaşlar
bakınız
bir sayı
giriniz
daha giriniz
ama şimdi bakın
bir sayı
giriniz
ahmet
bir sayı
daha giriniz
x eşittir
neden böyle
oldu sizce
c'de de
benzer
durumla
karşılaşmıştık
c kursuna
katılan
arkadaşlar
hatırlayacaklar
neden böyle
oldu
ilk girişte
tekrar edelim
orayı
girişi
şöyle yaptık
ya
dosya işlemlerinde
de önemli
olacak bu
ahmet
x değişikliğini
set etmek için
ve 4
karakterlerini
kullandı
ama
a karakteri
non digit
karakteri
olduğu için
ahmet'in
a'sını
almadı
ama
almadığı için
onu
buffer'dan da
ne yaptı
çıkartmadı
dolayısıyla
ancak
yeni bir girişin
yapılması için
ne yapılması
gerekiyor
buffer'dan
o karakterlerin
çıkartılması
gerekiyor
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
arkadaşlar
işte
bunun için
iStream
sınıfının
nesi var
bir
eee
fonksiyonu var
fonksiyonun
ismi
ignore
ignore fonksiyonu
şöyle bir fonksiyon
ezehen
mesela
c'nin
ignore fonksiyonu
arkadaşlar
fonksiyona
argüman olarak
ignore edeceği
karakter sayısını
veriyorsunuz
ve
fonksiyonun
aslında
iki tane
parametresi var
birinci parametre
bakın
tekrar
stream size
tipik olarak
arkadaşlar
eee
bir
türeş ismi
onu da göstereyim
bakın
stream size
aslında
şöyle yapalım
eee
hype it
stream size
name
tabi derleyiciye bağlı
tamamen
bunu da yazdıralım
mesela bende
stream size
hangi türmüş
şunu da kapatalım
evet
bende
arkadaşlar
8 byte'lık
işaretli
int türüymüş
o zaman
tekrar
konumuza
geri dönelim
örneğin
c'nin
ignore fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
birinci parametresi
default argüman
olarak
bir değerini
alıyor
ikinci parametresi
eof
değerine
oluyor
ama
şimdi ben
örneğin
çağrıyı
şöyle yaparsam
arkadaşlar
bu sefer
5 karakteri
ignore edecek
ama
ikinci parametre
o kadar
karakter
gelmeden
şimdi
ikinci parametreye
geçtiğimiz
karakterle
karşılaştırsa
durması için
mesela
şöyle bir
çağrı
yapsaydım
bu sefer
bu çağrı
ne anlama
gelecekti
bu streamin
bufferından
5 tane
karakteri
extracted
işte
birinci parametre
kaç tane
karakteri
extracted
edecek
ikinci parametre
ise
hangi karakteri
delimiter olarak
kullanacak
yani bu şu
demek
örneğin
5 karakter
yoksa
arkadaşlar
üçüncü
karakterden
sonraki
newline ise
yine
orada
duracak
ya da
şöyle
çağrı
yapsaydım
standart
inputtan
30 tane
karakteri
extracted
demiş
olacaktım
fakat
30 karakterden
önce
newline ile
karşılaştırsa
bu sefer
newline ile
da
extracted
ederek
arkadaşlar
işini
bitirecekti
burada
o yüzden
şöyle bir
idiom da
çok sık
kullanılıyor
sınıfın
ignore
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorsunuz
ve amacınız
newline'e
kadar
bütün karakterleri
ne yapmak
ignore
etmek
böylece
standart
inputun
bufferını
temizlemiş
oluyorsunuz
ama burada
bir problem var
o da
ne
bu durumda
bunun güvenli
olarak çalışması
için
birinci
parametreye
alabilecek
en büyük
değeri
vermemiz
gerekiyor
işte henüz
benim göstermediğim
aslında
arkadaşlar
bir
template
numeric limits
şimdi
limits
başlık dosyası
içinde
onu da dahil
edelim
bu daha önce
kullanmadığımız
bir başlık
dosyası
numeric limits
isimli
bir
template var
bakın
numeric limits
arkadaşlar
bunun
template
parametresi
türü
istiyor
bizden
örneğin
int
ve
max
fonksiyonu
ilgili türün
en büyük
değerini döndürüyor
min
fonksiyonu
da
ilgili türün
en küçük
değerini döndürüyor
yani
c'deki
makroları
kullanmak
yerine
örneğin
int
türünün
en büyük
değerini
kullanmak
için
numeric limits
int
açılımının
max
fonksiyonunun
tabi buradaki
max
statik
bir fonksiyon
geri dönüş
değerini
ve
minimum
değer içinde
min
fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değerini
kullanıyoruz
o zaman
az önceki
konumuza
geri dönecek
olursak
olabilecek
bütün karakterleri
newline'e
kadar
arkadaşlar
ignore
etmek için
c'nin
ignore
fonksiyonunu
çağıracağım
birinci
parametrenin
türü
stream
size'dı ya
nümerik limits'in
stream
size açılımı
max'ı
ve
newline
böylece
arkadaşlar
tüm
satırı
ignore
etmiş olacağım
hatta
bunu
doğrudan
bir manipülatör
haline de
getirebilirsiniz
bunu da manipülatör
yapalım
şimdi
stud
i stream
ref
arkadaşlar
ignore
line
parametresi
tıpkı
o stream
manipülatörlerinde
olduğu gibi
stud
i stream
ref
bu çağrı
da burada
olacak
tabi
ignore
fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değeri de
ilgili
sınıfa
referans
o yüzden
doğrudan
şöyle
yazabilirim
return
is'in
ignore
böylece
örneğin
bir giriş
yaparken
stream'in
buffer'ındaki
bütün
karakterleri
almak
için
int
x
y
bir deneyelim
see out
iki sayı
giriniz
see in
x
ignore
line
y
tabi bunu
parametreli
manipülatör de
yapabilirdik
o zaman
n tane
line'ı
ignore
edebilirdi
line
y
bu
kadar
böylece
örneğin
girişi
az önceki
gibi
yapsaydık
şu
şekilde
düzeltelim
ya da şöyle
yazın
see in x
see in
ignore line
bir sayı
giriniz
örneği
biraz
geçtim
bir sayı
daha
giriniz
ignore
line
y
see out
x eşittir
x
y eşit
y
bir sayı
ahmet
bakın şimdi
artık doğru
çalışıyor
anlaşıldı
değil mi
alan
tür eş
isimleri
var mı
derken
neyi
kastettik
buradaki
stream
size
zaten bir
type
alias
standart
kütüphanenin
kullandığı
bir
type
alias
peki
o zaman
bir ara
verelim
saat
diyelim
ve
20'de
devam
edeceğiz
arkadaşlar
şimdi
konuyu
biraz
değiştireceğiz
ve
stream
state
konusuna
döneceğiz
gireceğiz
daha doğrusu
daha sonra
tekrar
formatlamayla
ilgili
bir iki
tane daha
ufak detay
kaldı
ama onları da
ilerleyen saatlerde
anlatacağım
arkadaşlar
her stream
nesnesinin
bir
format
state
olduğunu
gördük
ama
stream
nesnelerinin
bir başka
state'i
özelliği
sağlık
durumlarını
gösteren
state
bu benim
uydurduğum
terim
yani
ingilizce
health
condition
anlamında
arkadaşlar
bir stream
nesnesi
işini
gören
doğru
durumda
işini
görebilecek
doğru
sağlıklı
sıhhatli
durumda
olabilir
bu durumda
o stream
nesnesini
kullanarak
bir giriş
çıkış
işlemi
yapabilirsiniz
yapmaya
aday
olabilirsiniz
demek
ama
bir stream
nesnesi
bir hata
durumunda
da
olabilir
bir hata
durumundaki
stream
nesnesi
işini
yapamayacak
bir stream
nesnesidir
işte
condition
state
interfezinde
bir fonksiyonlarla
biz
stream
condition
state'i
yani
benim
Türkçemle
akımın
sağlık
sıhhat
durumunu
net edebiliyoruz
ve
set edebiliyoruz
burada
c'nin
standart
kütüphanesinden
biraz farklı
olarak
eğer
stream
nesnemiz
işini
yapabilecek
durumda
değilse
hata
durumundaysa
bir okuma
ya da
yazma
işlemini
artık
stream
nesnesinin
ne
olduğuna
bağlı
olarak
yapma
girişiminde
bulunabilmek
için
önce
stream
nesnesini
sağlıklı
duruma
geri
kavuşturmamız
gerekiyor
işte
o
stream
nesnesinin
sağlıklı
işini
görebilir
durumuna
good state
deniyor
ve
gerçekten de
ismi
good olan
bir fonksiyon
var
arkadaşlar
bu konuda
maalesef
c++'ın
hangi konusu
karmaşık
değil ki
dikkatli
dinlemezsek
ve bazı
detayları
anlamazsak
biraz karmaşık
gelebilir
şimdi o zaman
bir stream
nesnesi
ya good state
ya da
good state
de değil
ama
hata
durumundaysa
hatanın
da
farklı
biçimleri
var
mesela
şu nedenle
hata durumunda
olabilir
streamden
okuma
yapmışızdır
ve
streamin
bufferında
hiçbir
karakter
kalmamıştır
yani
bufferda
bir karakter
olmadığı
için
artık
giriş
işlemi
başarısız
olmuştur
ve
ilk yapılan
akımda
karakter
kalmadığı
için yapılan
giriş işlemi
başarısız
olduğundan
akım
yani stream
yine
hata durumuna
düşmüştür
ama
bunun dışında
başka nedenlerle de
bir stream
nesnesi
hata durumunda
olabilir
örneğin
arkadaşlar
en tipik
senaryolardan biri
formatlama
uyumsuzluğu
düşünün
intürden bir
değişkeni
decimal
karakterlerle
set edeceksiniz
fakat
streamin
bufferından
gelen karakter
A
B
C
D
yani rakam
karakteri
olmayan
karakter
ya da
karakterler
bu durumda
giriş yapılamayacak
ama giriş
yapılamadığı
gibi
stream nesnesi
hata durumuna
düşecek
işte
burada
önce
bir hatadan
daha bahsedelim
arkadaşlar
öyle
hatalar
var ki
bunlar da
artık
recovery
mümkün
değil
yani
artık
stream nesnesinin
dışındaki
durumlar itibariyle
mesela işletim
sisteminde
genel bir
bellek problemi
var
ya da bir
nedenle
işletim
sistemi
düzeyinde
artık
okuma
yazma
işlemleri
yapılamıyor
yani
bizim
yazdığımız
kodla
doğrudan
ilgili
olmayan
şekilde
bu
duruma da
popüler olarak
bad state
deniyor
o zaman
akım nesnemiz
stream nesnemiz
ya good state
ya da
hata durumunda
ama hata durumunda
olması
a
e of
nedeniyle
hata
olabilir
format uyumsuzluğu
vesaire
nedeniyle
hata
olabilir
bir de
artık
tipik olarak
recovery'nin
mümkün olmadığı
örneğin
bellek
yetersizliği
gibi
nedenlerden
arkadaşlar
hata
oluşabilir
işte
interfesteki
ilk
fonksiyonlarımız
boolean
döndüren
stream'in
ismi
good
olan
arkadaşlar
ismi
e of
olan
ismi
pale
olan
arkadaşlar
ve ismi
bad
olan
fonksiyonlarımız
bunların
hepsinin
geri dönüş
değeri
arkadaşlar
bool
yani
good
fonksiyonu
boolean
true
döndürürse
akım
good
durumunda
ama
e of
fonksiyonu
true
döndürürse
akım
e of
durumunda
fail
fonksiyonu
true
döndürürse
akım
fail
durumunda
ve
bad
fonksiyonu
true
döndürürse
stream
bad
durumunda
hemen bunları
bir gösterelim
bunlardan
çok
giriş
akımları
için
daha önemli
örneklere
input
streams
üstünden
vereceğim
arkadaşlar
mesela
bakınız
int
x
cout
bir
sayı
giriniz
bir
ham
sayı
giriniz
c
in x
hatta
bir de
fonksiyon
yazalım
arkadaşlar
void
print
condition
state
stud
arkadaşlar
ios
ref
x
if
good
x
cout
stream
is
good
else
stream
is not
good
isn't
cout
here
ekleme
yapacağım
ama bakın
önce
giriş işlemini
yapmadan önce
print
condition
state
scene
herhangi
herhangi bir giriş işlemi yapmadığım için
beklendim
tabi ki
stream'in
good durumunda olması
stream is good
bir tam sayı girin
ve giriş işleminden sonra
tekrar
condition state'i
yazdırıyorum
arkadaşlar
stream is good
ama bakın şimdi bir tam sayı giriniz
ctrl z
enter
biliyorsunuz
windows sistemlerinde
unix sistemlerinde de
ctrl d
ctrl z
enter
standart input'un bufferını
boş bırakma
simülasyonu
şimdi artık
good durumunda değil
bir deneme daha yapalım
bir tam sayı giriniz
Ali
stream gördüğünüz gibi
yine
fail durumuna
düştü
good durumda
değil
gördüğünüz gibi
girişte problem
olduğu zaman
artık akım
stream
good durumunu
terk ediyor
ama diğerlerine de
bakalım
in
eof state
is not
in
eof state
çarnım fonksiyonu da
eof
bakın
ahmet
arkadaşlar
ahmet girişini yaptığımda
giriş başarısız oldu
ama eof state de değil
çünkü giriş işleminin
başarısız olmasının
nedeni
streamde karakter
olmayışı değil
ama şimdi bakın
ctrl z
enter
gördüğünüz gibi
akım good durumunda
değil
ama eof
durumunda
şimdi
fail'e bakalım
bu arada
cppreference.com'da
hangi durumlarda
hangi fonksiyonun
true ya da
false döndürdüğü
bir tablo halinde
verilmiş durumda
bu sefer
fail fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
stream is
in
failed
state
diyelim
belki doğru
ingilizce
on nasıl
in
failed
state
ve tekrar
çalıştıralım
bir tam sayı
girin
ekran çıktısına
bakınız
bir tam sayı
girin
ahmet
stream isn't
good
stream is
nothing
eof state
street
stream is
in
fail
state
arkadaşlar
eof durumunda
değil
şimdi
eof
yapalım
ctrl z
enter
bakın
hem
eof durumunda
hem de
fail durumunda
ve en sonunda
bad
fonksiyonu
x
x bad
stream is
in
bad
state
is not
in
bad
state
tekrar
tekrar giriş
işlemini
yapıyorum
arkadaşlar
şimdi ben
standart
input üstünde
bu
testleri
yapıyorum
ama
ilerleyen
saatlerde
dakikalarda
artık
bellek üstünde
okuma yazma
işlemlerine
ve dosyalar
üstünde
yapılan
file
input
operations
konusuna
geçeceğiz
bir tam sayı
giriniz
ctrl z
enter
bakın
bad state
de değil
ya da
ahmet
bad state
de değil
şimdi çok dikkatli
izlemenizi istiyorum
arkadaşlar
nasıl stream
nesnelerinin
fmt
flagstöründen
bir elemanı
var
ve
format
state'i
en azından
bir kısmını
bu elemanda
tutuyor ise
aynı şekilde
arkadaşlar
stream nesnelerinin
bir de
condition
state'ini
tutan
tipik olarak
bir veri elemanı
var
yine
bitleri
vasıtasıyla
tutuyor
burada
o bitleri
get etmek
ve set etmek
için
yine
en tepedeki
taban sınıfın
bazı
bitmask
constexpr
veri elemanları
var
arkadaşlar
bunlar şöyle
yazılıyor
yine en tepedeki
ios
base'in
ios base'in
good biti
aslında
0 değeri
yani bütün
bitleri 0 olan
sayı
arkadaşlar
ios base'in
fail biti
eof biti
ve ios base'in
bad biti
arkadaşlar
bir giriş
ya da çıkış
işleminden sonra
hatanın
olup olmadığına
ve hatanın ne
bağlı olarak
stream nesnesinin
state
değişkeninin
fail biti
eof biti
bad biti
bunlardan bir
ya da birden
fazlası
set ediliyor
bu sefer
biraz zamanı
oynamak için
bu bitleri
test eden
yazdığım
fonksiyonu
buraya
kopyalıyorum
nasıl
flex
fonksiyonu
format
flex'i
get ediyorsa
ismi
read state
olan
fonksiyonda
stream nesnesinin
arkadaşlar
condition
state'ini
get ediyor
eğer
geri dönüş
değeri
sıfırsa
bu good bit
durumu
demek
yani
hiçbir bit
set edilmemiş
bu durumda
stream
okey durumunda
ama
fail bitinin
set edilip
edilmediğini
read state'in
döndürdüğü
değerin
bitsel
v operatörüyle
fail bitinin
set edilip
edilmediğini
test ettim
altında
eof bit
bad bit
arkadaşlar
yine aynı şekilde
bakın
main fonksiyonu
içinde
see out
bir
sayı
giriniz
int x
see in x
display state
fonksiyonunu
girişten önce
bir kere
çağıralım
display state
see in
bakınız
akım normalde
good durumunda
dolayısıyla
hiçbir hata
biti
set edilmiş
durumda
değil
ama şimdi
giriş işleminden
sonra
tekrar
display state'i
çağırıyorum
ve
teker teker
bitleri
gözlüyoruz
stream
ok
ctrl z
enter
fail bit
is set
eof bit
efendim
ahmet
tahmin edin
eof bit
set edilmeyecek
bad bit
ama
fail bit
set edilecek
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
yani
bu bitleri
get edebilirsiniz
ya da set edebilirsiniz
ya da doğrudan
good
fail
eof
bad
fonksiyonlarına
çağrı yapabilirsiniz
arkadaşlar
mesela bakın
bir giriş işlemini
düşünün
izleyin
şimdi şu örnek
cppreference.com'dan
çok güzel konuyu
gösteren bir örnek
var ama
benim açıklamam
gerekiyor
biraz
bakar bakmaz
anlamanız
zor olabilir
arkadaşlar
formatlı
giriş fonksiyonlarının
geri dönüş
değeri
stream
referansıydı
öyle değil mi
ama
stream
nesnelerinin
operator
boğul
fonksiyonu
var
burası
çok çok
önemli
operator
boğul
fonksiyonu
stream
nesnesinin
lojik kontekste
kullanımına
olanak veriyor
mesela
size komik gelse de
ben
if c in
gibi bir
if deyimi yazsam
aslında burada
c in'in
operator
boğul
fonksiyonunu
implicit
kol ediyorum
çağırıyorum
yani böyle
böyle yazmakla
böyle yazmak
arasında
bir fark
yok
arkadaşlar c in
stream'in
operator
boğul
fonksiyonu
aslında
fail
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyor
ve fail
fonksiyonunun
değilini
döndürüyor
dolayısıyla
şöyle yazmakla
aslında
c in
fail
olmamışsa
demek
aynı anlamda
buraya kadar
takip edebildik mi
evet
şimdi gelelim
formatlı giriş
işlemlerine
ve formatlı
çıkış işlemlerine
arkadaşlar
operator
left shift
ve operator
right shift
fonksiyonlarının
geri dönüş
değeri
stream referansı
dolayısıyla
bu fonksiyon
çağrı ifadelerini
doğrudan
lojik bağlamda
da kullanabilirsiniz
örneğin
lütfen dikkatli
takip edin
şöyle bir
döngü
oluştursaydım
while
c in
x
bu da
kitaplarda
çok olan bir
kod
hem de kitapların
ilk saygılarında
arkadaşlar
bakın
aslında burada
nasıl bir işlem
yapılmış olacak
c'nin
operatör
right shift
fonksiyonu
çağrılacak
ona x
argüman olarak
gönderilecek
bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri c'nin
nesnesinin
kendisi
onun içinde
operatör
boğul fonksiyonu
çağrılacak
yani eğer siz
böyle bir döngü
oluşturursanız
tabi okuma
işlemi dosyadan
da yapılıyor
olabilir
ne zaman
bu döngüden
çıkacak
döngünün
herhangi bir
turunda
giriş
başarısız
olduğunda
giriş
başarısız
olduğunda
akım
good
durumundan
çıkacak
ve fail
durumuna
gelecek
fakat
sınıfın
bir de
operatör
değil
fonksiyonu
var
yani
örneğin
şöyle bir
ifade
yazmak
değil
c'nin
neye eş
değer
c'nin
arkadaşlar
operatör
değil
fonksiyonla
çağrı
yapmaya
eş
değer
tahmin edebildiğiniz
gibi
operatör
değil
fonksiyonu
da
sınıfın
fail
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyor
dolayısıyla
söyleyin
bakalım
şimdi
örneğin
if
c'nin
x
buraya da
lojik değil
operatörünü
koyarsam
hem
burada
giriş işlemini
yapmış olacağım
daha doğrusu
yapma girişiminde
bulunacağım
ama giriş işlemi
fail olduğunda
yani akımı
fail state de
bıraktığında
if'in doğru
kısmına
girecek
isterseniz
deneyelim
bakın
see out
hatalı
giriş
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
see in
x
bunun geri dönüş
değeri
see in
nesnesinin
kendisi
arkadaşlar
ve
operatör
değil
fonksiyonu
çağırılıyor
değil mi
burada
neden
operatör
değil fonksiyonu
çağırmış
oluyoruz
çünkü
şu ifadenin
kendisi
aslında
see in
nesnesi
değil mi
yani
böyle yazmakla
örneğin
see in
nokta
operatör
right shift
x
ve
nokta
operatör
değil
fonksiyonu
çağırmak
aynı anlamda
arkadaşlar
deminki kodu
tekrar
döngü koduna
gelelim
ve orada
ne olduğunu
runtime'da
birlikte
gözleyelim
bakın
var
see in
x
see out
buraya da şöyle şık bir ifade yazalım
x
çarpı
eşittir
x çarpı
x
bakın ne zaman döngüden çıkacağına
giriş başarılı
ahmet
giriş başarısız
döngüden
çıktı
o zaman bir kez daha
tekrar edelim
burası çok kritik
özellikle dosya işlemlerinde
operator
left
chip
ve operator
right
chip
fonksiyonları
yani formatta
giriş çıkış fonksiyonları
stream
nesnesinin
kendisini
döndürüyor
yani
geri dönüş
değerleri
değeri
türü
o stream
ref
ya da
i stream
ref
fakat aynı zamanda
stream nesnelerinin
hem operator
bool
fonksiyonları var
hem de
operator
logical
not
fonksiyonları var
operator
bool
fonksiyonu
fail
fonksiyonunun
lojik
değerini döndürürken
operator
değil
fonksiyonu
yani operator
logical
not
fonksiyonu
doğrudan
fail
fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değerini döndürüyor
dolayısıyla
if
while
for
gibi döngü
deyimlerinde
doğrudan
formatta
giriş çıkış
ifadelerini
kullandığımızda
ya da
stream nesnelerini
değil
lojik değil
operatörün
operandı
yaptığımızda
ya da
stream nesnelerini
doğrudan
lojik operatörlerin
operandı
yaptığımızda
operatör
bool
fonksiyonunun
çağrılmasını
sağlıyoruz
mesela
bakınız
şöyle bir kod
ilk defa
karşılaşanlara
biraz tuhaf
geliyor
if
see in
see out
ne demek bu
see in de
see out da
afiyette ise
sağlıklıysa
saatliyse
if'in
doğru kısmına
girecek
ya da
şöyle yazarsan
if
değil
see in
ya da
değil
see out
bu stream
nesnelerinden
herhangi biri
fail durumundaysa
yani
giriş ya da
çıkış işlemi
yapamayacak durumdaysa
if'in
doğru kısmına
girecek
buraya kadar
anlaşıldı mı
o zaman
biraz karmaşık gibi
görünen
cppreference.com'da
verilen örneği
anlamaya
çalışabiliriz
arkadaşlar
şimdi önce
şu while döngüsüne
bakın
çok şık bir kod ama
ilk defa
tanışanları
biraz zorluyor
while döngü
deyiminde
logic v operatörüyle
oluşturulmuş
bir ifade
görmektesiniz
dolayısıyla
logic v operatörünün
doğru değer
vermesi
durumunda
döngünün
gövdesine
girecek
logic v operatörü
yanlış değer
ürettiğinde
döngüden
çıkacak
arkadaşlar
peki
nasıl oluyor da
while parantezi
içindeki ifade
sentaks hatası
oluşturmuyor
son derece
basit
çünkü
burada
bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş değeri
cout
ve
cout nokta
operatör
bool fonksiyonu
çağrılıyor
burada da
yine
çağrılan
c in
nesnesinin
operatör
değil
fonksiyonu
yine
bool in
değer döndürüyor
dolayısıyla
burada
yanlış
değerin
oluşması
ve döngüden
çıkması
için
ya arkadaşlar
birinci ifadenin
yanlış olması
ya da
ikinci ifadenin
yanlış olması
gerekiyor
ikinci ifadenin
yanlış olması
demek
operatör
değilin
buraya
dikkat
arkadaşlar
false
değer döndürmesi
demek
yani
girişin
başarılı
olması
demek
eğer
giriş
başarısız
olursa
buraya
dikkat
eo
fonksiyonu
çağrılmış
eo
fonksiyonu
çağrılması
demek
demek ki
standart
input'un
bufferına
giriş
yapılmamış
ama
bir şeye
dikkat edin
şu anda
eof durumundaysa
akım
fail state
değil mi
döngünün
bir sonraki
turunda
giriş
işleminin
yapılabilmesi
için
ne
gerekiyor
stream'in
yine
good
duruma
gelmesi
gerekiyor
işte
sınıfın
clear isimli
fonksiyonuna
argüman
göndermezsem
aslında bu
default argüman
gönderdiğim
anlamına
geliyor
clear
fonksiyonu
ne yapıyor
akımı
tekrar
good state
döndürüyor
oraya anladık mı
clear fonksiyonunun
ne yaptığını
anladık mı
dolayısıyla
döngünün bir sonraki
turunda
yine okuma
girişimi
yapılacak
eğer burada
clear fonksiyonunu
çağırmasaydım
okuma işlemi
yine başarısız
olacaktı
yani okuma işlemi
girişiminde bile
bulunmayacaktı
ama
if'in yanlış
kısmına
girdiğimizde
buraya dikkat
demek ki
hem okumada
hata olmuş
ama
eof durumunda
da değil
demek ki
format uyuşmazlığı
var
olduğu için
streamdeki
karakterlerde
ekstrakt edilmedi
dolayısıyla
giriş işleminin
tekrar yapılabilmesi
için
stream'in
bufferındaki
karakterleri
bufferdan
çıkartmam
gerekiyor
ama burada
da bir hata
mesajı
vermek
istediğim için
bir string
değişkenine
get my
fonksiyonuyla
okuma yapıyorum
böylece
kullanıcıya
böyle bir
mesajı
verebiliyorum
şimdi deneyelim
bakınız
fail olmadı
giriş başarılı
döngüden çıktı
is in
ctrl z
enter
eof fonksiyonu
true değer
döndürdü
clear fonksiyonu
çağrıldı
böylece
bir okuma
işlemi daha
yapmaya
muktedir
haldeyiz
evet
ahmet
bu sefer
arkadaşlar
if'in
yanlış kısmına
girdi
yine
stream'i
clear ettim
yani
hata
durumundan
çıkarttım
bir string'e
okuma yaptım
okuduğum
yazıyı
yazdırdım
ve bunun
geçersiz bir
tam sayı
olduğu
mesajını
verdim
yine
mesela
neco
neco is not
a valid integer
ömer faruk
is not a valid
integer
ilk döngüden
çıktı
örnek
herhalde çok güzel
konuyu da
çok iyi anlatan
bir örnek
şimdi buradaki
clear fonksiyonundan
biraz bahsetmek
istiyorum
dikkatli izleyelim
arkadaşlar
bakınız
clear fonksiyonu
hata bayraklarını
sıfırlıyor
az önceki
şu kodu
hatta
biraz
bekleteceğim
şu bitleri
sınayan
fonksiyon
koduna
geri dönelim
işte burada
bakınız
çok dikkatli izleyin
şimdi
diyelim ki
giriş
başarısız
buraya kadar
bir
debug edelim
bir sayı
giriniz
ahmet
bakın
fail biti set
diğer bitler
set edilmemiş
alem birazdan cevap vereyim
olur mu
şurası bölünmesin
evet
arkadaşlar bakın şimdi
c'nin
clear fonksiyonu
takip edebiliyor muyuz
c'nin
clear fonksiyonunu
çağırdığında
ne yapıyor
argüman göndermediğim zaman
stream yine
good state'e
döndürüyor
yani artık
tekrar
okuma işlemi
yapmaya
aday
bu okumanın
başarılı olacağı
anlamına gelmiyor
ama en azından
okuma işlemi
yapılacak
bakınız
stream is
okey
bir sayı
giriniz
ahmet
fail biti set
stream is
okey
clearing ne yaptığını
anladık mı
fakat
clearing
bir overloadu
daha var
bu da
bizden
arkadaşlar
ios state
değerini istiyor
izleyin
display state
see in
clear
ios'un
bad biti
yani aynı zamanda
bir set fonksiyonu
şimdi tekrar
display state fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
bakınız
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
bad bit
is
set
efendim
şimdi
tekrar
clear fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
bu sefer
fail bit
değerini
veriyorum
fail bit
değerini
alıyor
arkadaşlar
tekrar
bakın
display state
bir daha display state
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
clear fonksiyonunu
önce iyi anlayalım
fail biti
bir şeye dikkat edin
clear
ilave olarak
o biti
set etmiyor
doğrudan
ios state'i
bu değere çekiyor
yani örneğin
clear fonksiyonunu
şöyle çağırsaydım
ne olacaktı
Alihan
see in
clear'i
ios'un
bad biti
eof biti
ios'un
fail biti
söyleyin
arkadaşlar
3 bit de
set edilmiş
olacaktı
display state
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
bakın
fail biti
set
eof biti
bad bit
is set
ama sınıfın
bir de
set state
isimli
fonksiyonu
var
yani
örneğin
ce'nin
set state'i
ios'un
bad biti
bu
sadece
bu biti
birliyor
diğer bitlere
dokunmuyor
dolayısıyla
bunu
çok iyi
görmek için
şöyle bir kod
yazabiliriz
bakın
aradaki parka
neydi ismi
fonksiyonumuzun
display state
bu örnek
çok önemli
iki fonksiyonu
birbiriyle karıştırma
eğilim çok fazla
bakın
display state
see in
hatta buraya
bir de şöyle
arkadaşlar
çizgi satırı
yazdıran
bir kod ekleyelim ki
fonksiyon çağrıları
birbirinden
ayrık görünsün
display state
see in
clear ios'un
eof biti
tekrar display state
clear
bad bit
tekrar display state
clear
fail bit
tekrar display state
ne olduğunu göreceğiz
sadece
eof bit
set edilmiş
sadece
bad bit
set edilmiş
sadece
fail bit
set edilmiş
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
ama burada
clear fonksiyonunu
çağırmak yerine
arkadaşlar
az önceki
fonksiyonunu
çağırsaydım
yani
set state
fonksiyonunu
çağırsaydım
bakın
set state
sadece
bu bayrakları
set edecekti
yani diğerlerine
dokunmayacaktı
izlenin
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
önce eof bit
set edilmişti
sonra bad bit
de set edildi
arkadaşlar
sonra
fail bit
de set edildi
anlaşıldı mı
evet
sizin sorunuza
gelecek olursak
c'de de böyle
c++'da da böyle
bir giriş işleminin
başarısızlığı
format uyumsuzluğu
nedeniyle ise
o karakterler
standart inputun
ya da genel olarak
streaming bufferından
çıkartılmıyor
dolayısıyla
bir daha okuma işlemi
yapma girişiminde
bulunsak
yine başarısız
olacak
yani
örneğin şöyle bir
kod yazsaydım
izleyin
see out
bir tam sayı
girin
burayı
doğru anlamamış
olabiliriz
halen için
söylemiyorum
bir tane arkadaşlarım için
int x
arkadaşlar
see in x
see out
bir tam sayı
daha giriniz
bakınız
see in
x
şimdi ben burada
stream'deki karakterleri
çıkartmamışsam
ilk giriş
hatalı yapılmışsa
bir daha
benden giriş
istemeyecek ki
stream'deki karakterleri
tekrar
kullanma girişiminde
bulunacak
arkadaşlar
clear
fonksiyonunu
çağırsam dahi
see in
clear'i
anlaşıldı mı
bakın
see out
x eşittir
x
new line
bir tam sayı girin
ahmet
arkadaşlar
bir tam sayı daha girin
yine giriş yapamadım
ne için
stream'de halen o
ahmet yazısının
karakterleri var
dolayısıyla
onları stream'den
çıkartmam lazım
işte bir önceki örnekte
onları stream'den
çıkartmak için
get line
fonksiyonunu
çağırmıştım
ya da başka bir yol
ignore fonksiyonunu
çağırarak
onları
bu
iStream
see in
nesnesinin
buffer'ından
çıkartmakta
olabilirdi
anlaşıldı mı
evet
peki
arkadaşlar
devam edelim
o zaman
buradaki fonksiyonlar
şunlar
değil mi
şöyle bir özetleyelim
good fonksiyonu
bunlar üye fonksiyon
şöyle
eo fonksiyonu
bad fonksiyonu
ve
pale fonksiyonu
state'i get etmek için
read state fonksiyonu
ve
bitlerin
değerini
get etmek için
onların setme
unsetme olduğunu
anlamak için
maskelerimiz
ios'un
good biti
zaten bildiğimiz
sıfır değeri
ios'un
eof biti
fail biti
ve
ios'un
bad biti
sınıfın
clear fonksiyonu
var
default argüman
olarak
good bit
değerini
alıyor
ve
verdiğiniz değeri
set ediyor
ama
akımın
arkadaşlar
set state
fonksiyonu
verdiğiniz
değeri
ilave
bayrak
olarak
set ediyor
diğer bayraklara
dokunmuyor
ios'un
bir
manipülatör
var
bakın
reset
ios
flex
bu
bu da
doğrudan
hata bayraklarını
sıfırlıyor
yani
örneğin
bir giriş işleminde
siz
chaining'i bozmadan
hata bayraklarını
clear etmek
istiyorsanız
reset
ios flexi
ne yapabilirsiniz
arkadaşlar
kullanabilirsiniz
bu parametreli
manipülatör
dolayısıyla
hangi
değeri
verirseniz
o değeri
alacak
örneğin
ios'un
arkadaşlar
good biti
gibi
bu da
modern c++
şeklendi
eskiden olan
bir manipülatör
değildi
işte
stream state'i
get etmenin yolu
ve set etmenin yolu
bunlar
özellikle dosya işlem
arkadaşlar
bakın
bunlar hep
stream nesneleriyle
ilgili
ama
ben şimdi
henüz
string stream'leri
anlatmadığım için
file stream'leri
bütün örnekleri
hep
stot cout'un
ilişkin olduğu
o stream sınıfı
ve
slot c nesnesinin
ilişkin olduğu
i stream sınıfı
üstünden verdim
ama hep böyle
olmayacak
şimdi o zaman
hemen
ikinci
arkadaşlar
stream sınıfımıza
geçiyoruz
arkadaşlar
bellekten
okuma ve yazma
işlemleri
yapmak için
3 tane
sınıfımız var
o stream sınıfından
kalıtım yoluyla
elde edilen
o string stream
i stream
sınıfından
kalıtım yoluyla
elde edilen
i string stream
ve
oil stream
sınıfından
kalıtım yoluyla
elde edilen
string stream
şimdi burayı
çok dikkatli
izleyelim
soru
her
i string
nesnesi
her
i string
stream
nesnesi
aynı zamanda
burada
bu arada
şurada
ben de
daldım
underscore
karakterleri
yok
tabii ki
evet
her
i string
stream
nesnesi
aynı zamanda
string stream
nesnesi
aynı zamanda
i stream
nesnesi
midir
evet
o zaman
i string stream
sınıfı
türünden
bir nesneyle
ben
tıpkı
c in nesnesi
ile yaptığım
gibi
condition
state
fonksiyonlarını
ya da
format fonksiyonlarını
örneğin
setf'yi
ansetf'yi
çağırabilir
miyim
evet
manipülatörlerimi
kullanabilir
miyim
evet
yani
olsa olsa
i string
stream'in
ilave
fonksiyonları
var
fazlası
ama
eksiği
yok
bakın
kalıtımın
çok tipik
bir örneği
yine
i string
stream
sınıfı
okuma
interfezine
o string
stream
sınıfı
formatlı
yazma
interfezine
string
stream
sınıfı
ise
hem okuma
hem yazma
interfezine
sahip
eğer
bir
output
işlemini
bellek üstünde
yapacaksanız
o string
stream
sınıfını
bir
okuma
işlemini
bellek üstünde
yapacaksanız
i string
stream
sınıfını
kullanıyorsunuz
hemen
o string
stream
ile
başlayalım
arkadaşlar
çok basit bir örnek
bakın
benim
int türden bir değişkenim var
değeri
efendim
double türden bir değişkenim var
değeri
3.7623
hatta
bir tane
string
destem var
destemin
değeri de
bir yazı
olsun
string
str
ya da name
rasul
şimdi ben şöyle bir çıkış işlemi yapsaydım
see out
arkadaşlar
hex
manipülatörleri kullanıyorum
show base
uppercase
x
borçluk
arkadaşlar
set
precision
ayo manipü
dahil etmeyin
evet etmişim
set
precision
diyelim ki
fix
devil
arkadaşlar bir boşluk daha
name
buraya dikkat
şimdi
bakınız
konsola
bu formatlama özellikleriyle
böyle bir çıkış yaptı değil mi
0x
ea
space
3.7623
şimdi
o string stream sınıfı türünden
bir nesne oluşturuyorum
o string stream
o
s
ve
tek yaptığım
arkadaşlar
izleyin
tek yaptığım
cout
bu arada
bunların başlık dosyası
s
stream
onu da hemen söyleyelim
az önce söylemeyi ihmal ettik
yani
string stream
sınıflarını
kullanmak için
ister
i string stream
ister o string stream
ister string stream
s
stream başlık dosyasını
include etmeliyiz
şimdi bakın
cout'u kullandığım
yerde
osc'yi
kullanıyorum
hiçbir fark yok
derken
çıkışı
nereye yapacak
bellek üstüne
üstünde yapacak
yani çıkışın
bellek üstünde yapılması
ne demek
bunu bir yazı olarak
elde edeceğiz
peki necati o yazıyı
nasıl elde edeceğim
son derece
basit
yazıyı elde etmek
için
sınıfın
str isimli
fonksiyonunu
argüman
göndermeden
yani parametresi
olmayan
str fonksiyonu
overloadunu
çağıracaksınız
o size
bir stut
string döndürecek
yani
osc'nin
strs'i
artık bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş değerinden
aldığınız
stringi
dilediğiniz gibi
kullanabilirsiniz
ister
stream'e verin
bakın
ister
bunda
herhangi bir
string operasyonu
yapın
mesela bu
string
sadece bunun
bir string olduğunu
göstermek için
auto
s
ya da
str
eşittir
osc'nin
arkadaşlar
str'si
ve
algoritm başlık
dosyasını
ekleyeyim
diyelim ki
reverse
algoritmasını
çalıştıralım
reverse
str
begin
end
tekrar
yazdıralım
yani pek
yapmam gereken
o string
stream
sınıfını
str
isimli
fonksiyonunu
çağırmak
arkadaşlar
burada
aynı değişken
ismini
kullandığım
için
zaten
amacım
şunu
yazdırmaktı
siyahat
bir şey
silindim
siyahat
str
evet
değerleyip
çalıştırıyorum
görüyorsunuz
yazı
ters çevrili
yalnız
bir şeye
dikkat edin
arkadaşlar
siz yazdıkça
aynı bellek
alanına
yazıyı
ekleyecek
yani örneğin
şöyle bir kod
yazarsam
izleyin
burayı özellikle
çok dikkatli
izlememiz gerekiyor
çünkü çok sık
yapılan bir hata
örneğin
şöyle bir kod
yazsaydım
bir
o string
stream
nesnem
olsaydı
ve döngünün
her turunda
ossi
deseydim
ve döngünün
her turunda
sınıfın
str
fonksiyonunu
çağırıp
onun geri dönüş
değerini
standart
alt kuta
yazdırsaydım
ekran
çıktısı
şöyle mi
olacaktı
alt satırda
yoksa
şöyle mi
olacaktı
alt satırda
0 1
0 1 2
anladınız değil mi
ikincisi
bravo
bu hata
çok sık
yapılıyor
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
eğer
aynı
stream
nesnesini
tekrar
hiçbir
yazı
yokmuş
gibi
kullanacaksanız
bu sefer
set fonksiyonu
olan
str
yi
çağıracaksınız
yani
örneğin
o ss'nin
set fonksiyonu
boş yazı
geçin
arkadaşlar
str
fonksiyonu
setlerden
çıktı
şimdi
bakın
artık
her defasında
tekrar
boş hale
gelecek
anlaşıldı mı
arkadaşlar
şimdi
bu
string
stream
sınıfı
ile
istediğim gibi
formatlamayı da
yapabilirim
değil mi
yani örneğin
bakın bu örneğe
dikkat edin
film kelimde bir
tarih var
int
d
m
y
siyah
gün
ay
yıl
olarak
bir
tarih
girin
enter
ay
y
evet
ve
girişin doğru
olarak
yapıldığını
düşünelim
hatta
kontrol
yapmayacağım
ve arkadaşlar
yani bu
herhangi bir
fonksiyondan
gelen
günay
yıl
değeri de
olabilirdi
ben
ben şimdi
ilgili
uygulamada
bir
log dosyası
oluşturmam
gerekiyor
ama
log dosyasında
arkadaşlar
bu
günay
yılla
ismini vereceğim
yani örneğin
log dosyamın
ismi
nokta
txt
olacak
dolayısıyla
bu yazıyı
elde etmem
gerekir
değil mi
bakın
çok güzel
bir örnek
bu yazıyı
elde etmem
gerekir
değil mi
bu yazıyı
elde etmenin
yol
aslında en kolay
yolu
format kütüphanesini
kullanmak
ama
c++
standardı
aynı işi
string
o string
stream
sınıfını
kullanarak
yapabilir
miyim
tabi ki
bakın
o string
stream
oss
ama
formatlama
özelliklerini
değiştiriyorum
oss
arkadaşlar
fill
doldurma karakteri olarak 0'ı kullanmasını istedim
evet
bakın
oss
set v
oyunman ip dahil edildi
d
ondan sonra
arkadaşlar
underscore
yine set v
m
underscore
yine
artık set v'ye ihtiyacım yok
ye
ve şimdi bakın
diyelim ki
dosya ismini bir string
olarak
elde edeceğim
auto
filename
eşittir
oss'nin
str'si
cout
başında
sonunda
boşluk
olmadığını
göstermek için
böyle yazıyorum
filename
düzelteceğim
evet
bakınız
arkadaşlar
bakın
mesela şöyle bir fonksiyonu ben çok sık kullanıyorum
blog dosyaları için
izleyin
get
current
time
fonksiyonun geri dönüşü
diğeri
still
string
bakın
get current
time
ne yapacak
bakalım
kaç kişi
atabilecek
c
time
başlık dosyasını
dahil ediyorum
time
underscore
t
stack
stutt
time
bu fonksiyonları biliyorsunuz artık c'den
now ptr
arkadaşlar
auto
tp
eşittir
local time
bu da standart c kütüme nesnesinden gelen fonksiyon
adres
sec
şimdi artık biliyorsunuz
geri dönüş değeri olan local time'ın adresteki yapı nesnesinin elemanlarından
broken down time fonksiyonlarını arkadaşlar
broken down time değerlerini çekebilirim
evet evet
alan date kılasında böyle bir örnek vardı
o zaman
bunu bir yazı olarak elde etmek için format kütüphanesini kullanmıyorum ki
kullansam daha kolay olurdu
stutt
o string stream
o ss
o ss'nin
fili
biraz uzun olacak ama
o ss
set v2
arkadaşlar
tp
ok
tm underscore
md
alt pire
şimdi bundan sonra skor kolay olacak
set v2
pp
arkadaşlar
ok
tm underscore
mon
artı bir
set v4
tm underscore
hatırlıyorsunuz değilim bunları year
artı
sonra
set v2
tm underscore
arkadaşlar
saniye
saat dakika saniye
ağır
min
underscore
underscore'ları unutmayalım yalnız
evet biraz zahmetli ama
ne yapalım format kütüphanesini
kullanmıyoruz şimdi
set v2
a gün yazdık
ay yıl yazdık
şimdi
arkadaşlar
saatteydi sıra değil mi
tp
tm underscore
ağır
underscore
min
ve
sek
return
o ss
stl
evet bakın artık
herhangi bir yerde
noklama yaparken
auto
stl
ya da doğrudan standart
alıp da verelim
see out
get
current time
evet şu
benim derliği için
bu makroyu istiyorum
görürsünüz
takip edebildik mi
evet
arkadaşlar
bakın şimdi
şöyle bir örnek
çok şık
ama anlamakta
biraz zorluk çekebilirsiniz
ama önce
o string stream'i
bir bitirelim
buraya kadar
o string stream
sınıfıyla ilgili
anlamadığımız bir şey
var mı
arkadaşlar
hatta bakın
modern c++'da
şunu bile
yapabiliyorsunuz
bu soru
denekten de
eski c++'da
yoktu
bu
o string stream
i string stream
nesnelerini
temporary object olarak
bile kullanabiliyorsunuz
yani örneğin
şöyle bir kod yazsam
o string stream
artık dosyaları gitmiş
bakın o string stream
geçici nesne
takip edebiliyor muyuz
örneğin
necati
int x
sadece çalıştığını
göstermek istiyorum
x
nokta
jpeg
buraya kadar
herhangi bir hata yok
şimdi
bunu öncelik parantezi
içine alayım
sınıfın
str fonksiyonunu
çağırayım
bu bile legal
yani
temporal object üstünde bile
yapabilirim
cout
gelelim
okuma tarafına
okuma tarafı
biraz daha önemli
buradaki sınıfımızın
ismi
i string stream
arkadaşlar
bir stringle ya da
bir c stringle
başlatabiliyorsunuz
mesela
i string stream
iss
buraya dikkat
çift kırılık içinde
şimdi artık
c nesnesini
nasıl kullanıyorsam
iss nesnesini
da aynı şekilde
kullanabilirim
mesela şöyle bir kod
yazabilir miyim
int x
while
iss
x
cout
çok kullanışlı
izleyin
görüyor musunuz
arkadaşlar
bunlar
standart input'tan
gelseydi
nasıl
ne yapacaksam
şimdi de aynı işi
ya da aynı işleri
yapabiliyorum
hatta bakın
mülakatlerde sorular
çok tipik bir soru var
diyorlar ki
standart input'tan
bir yazı alın
her satıra
o yazının
kelimelerini
yazdırın
aslında çok kolay
değil mi
hadi yapalım bunu
bakın
cout
bir
yazı girin
get line
get line'ı hatırlıyorsunuz
string sınıfını bu sefer
unutmayalım
include etmeyi
string
get line
bir tane string
nesnesi alıyorum
string
bu örneğe çok dikkatli
izleyin line
get line
see in
arkadaşlar
virgül
line
böylece yazıyı
string nesnesine
aldım
şimdi bakın
iStringStream
iss
ben hep bu ismi
kullanıyorum
sizi rahatsız etmesin
arkadaşlar
bunun geri dönüş
değerini
bazen bir tuş
kombinasyonuna
basıyorum
birden
ekran kayboluyor
ondan sonra
uğraş babam
uğraştı
tamam şimdi oldu
bakın
get line'ın geri dönüş
değerini
string değişkeninde
tuttum
işte line değişkeninde
şimdi
iss nesnesini
construct ederken
line'ı
argüman olarak
verdim
buraya kadar
takip edebildik mi
o zaman
girişi de bir
string'e verebilirim
değil mi
string word
bu tipik
en tipik
mülakat sorularından
biri
çok arkadaşıma
hep bunu soruyorlar
arkadaşlar
bakın
birçok arkadaşıma
soruyu sormuşlar
diye düzeltelim
while
iss
word
takip edin
takip edin şimdi
see out
hatta şöyle
güzel
kelimeleri
sayısını da
verelim
in
cnt
siyahat
artı artı artı
artı artı cnt
bir boşluk
new line
bak ne kadar güzel
şey
derliyorum
bir yazı girin
bugün
c++
kursunun
57'ci
bilmiyorum
hatırlamıyorum
ama
dersini
işliyoruz
hayırlı
olsun
arkadaşlar
aldığım yazı bu
bakın
birinci kelime bugün
ikinci kelime
c++
kursunun
57.
dersini
izliyoruz
yanlış yazılmış
hayırlı olsun
arkadaşlar
kodu anladık mı
demek ki
c nesnesinden
nasıl okuma
yapabiliyorsam
aynı interfej
kullanarak
aynı formatlama
olanaklarından
faydalanarak
arkadaşlar
giriş yapabilirim
bakın şimdi
daha da
esprili bir
kod yazacağım
herkes çok
dikkatli izlesin
see out
toplanacak
sayıları
giriniz
espireye
bakın şimdi
get line
see in
line
line değişkenini
yine
tanımlayacağım
string
line
bakın
girişimde
böyle yapılacak
toplanacak
sayıları
girin
efendim
girişi böyle yapacağım
ama
bunlar yazı aslında
değil mi
ama şöyle yapabilirim
int x
int
sum
while
arkadaşlar
istring stream
nesnemi
oluşturmamışım
onu da oluşturayım
evet
istring stream
is
line
iss
while
line
iss
x
sum
artı eşit
x
Toplanacak sayıları giriniz.
12, 23, 45, 67, 89, 21, 43, 56, 55, 20, 30, 40, 90, 87, 123, toplam 801.
Yine aynı şekilde bunları bir konteynere da atabilirdim değil mi?
Mesela kodu biraz daha değiştirelim.
Arkadaşlar bakın bakın şimdi çok şık olacak.
Vektör.
Sadece şurayı değiştireyim.
Stude Vektör'ün int açılımı IVEC.
IVEC'in Reserv'ı 200.
IVEC, Pushback, X.
Algoritim başlık dosyasını dahil ediyorum.
Vektör'ü sort ediyorum.
Sort, IVEC BEGIN, IVEC AND.
See out.
Girdiğiniz sayılar.
Copy, IVEC BEGIN, IVEC AND.
İteratör başlık dosyasını ekleyeceğim.
Ostream iteratörün.
Int açılımı.
See out.
Arkadaşlar.
Ayıraç olarak da New Line.
Evet.
Değerliyorum.
Toplanacak sayıları giriniz.
12, 34, 5, 98.
Promptu değiştirmemişim.
2, 88, 23, 45, 34, 67.
Girdiğiniz sayılar.
2, 5, 12.
Küçükten büyüğe yazdım.
Distrink stream sınıfı belirli yerlerde çok işe yarıyor.
Arkadaşlar.
Bu arada bakın.
Çok tipik.
Üretimde de karşımıza çıkan bir problem.
Yine date ödevinde aslında şimdi anlatacağım özelliği kullanabilirdiniz.
Ama tabi o dönem itibariyle bunu anlatmadığım için yapma imkanımız yoktu.
Arkadaşlar.
İzleyin.
Şimdi diyelim ki benim bir date sınıfım var.
Class date
Public
İki dakikada bitireceğim merak etmeyin.
Date
Int
D
Bütün sınıfı yazacak halim yok.
Int M
Int Y
Efendim kodu da şöyle olsun.
Şunlar da private veri elemanları.
Private
Int
M
D
Y
İşte klasik bir parametrali konstruktör.
studostream.rev.os
Arkadaşlar
const.date.rev.d
Ve şu şekilde yazdırıyor.
return.os
d'nin md'si
işte diyelim ki bir boşluk
arkadaşlar ya da çizgi
d'nin mm
ve d'nin bir boşlukta
ya da tri
d'nin md'si
Şimdi çok dikkatli izleyin.
Mesela see out
date
3.6.1988
Buraya kadar takip edebildik mi?
Evet.
Yerliyorum.
Çalıştırıyorum.
3.6.1988
Ama şimdi bakınız.
Oyun manip başlık dosyasını dahil ettim.
Arkadaşlar
Ayomanip
Ve diyorum ki
sola dayalı olarak
hatırlıyorsunuz değil mi
manipülatörleri
40 karakterlik alana
bu tarihi yaz
ondan sonra da
Necati yaz.
Ama işler
benim istediğim gibi
gitmeyecek.
Nedenini kim söyleyecek?
Neden bu kod yanlış?
Aslında 40 karakterlik
alana
sola dayalı olarak
tarihi yazacak.
Ondan sonra
boşluklar olacak
ve sonra da
Necati yazacak.
İstediğim bu.
Yani nasıl bir tam sayıyı
40 karakterlik
alana yazdıysam
arkadaşlar
neden olmayacağını
tahmin ediyorsunuz değil mi?
SETV manipülatörü
sadece
ilk çıkışı
yapılacak
öğe için değil mi?
Hayır hayır
Resul
problem orada değil.
Bakın
ilk olarak ne yazdırılıyor?
Ayın günü.
İzleyin ne olduğunu.
Arkadaşlar
gördünüz mü?
Bakın
3'ten sonra
3'ü 40 karakterlik
alana yazdı.
Oysa ben
3'ü 40 karakterlik
alana yazmasını
istemiyorum ki.
Tarihi 40 karakterlik
alana yazmasını
istiyorum.
Resul
anladınız mı
problemin ne olduğunu?
Evet.
Arkadaşlar
izleyin.
Şimdi
peki
problemi nasıl
çözebiliriz?
Ya son derece
basit.
Eğer ben
burada
tek bir çıkış
yapsaydım
set ve o çıkışa
ilişkin olacaktı
değil mi?
O zaman
bunu
stream başlık
dosyası
dahil edilmiş
stud
o string stream
türünden
bir nesne
oluştururum.
Çıkışı
bu nesneye
yaparım.
Ama
neyi geri döndürürüm?
Return
arkadaşlar
o s s
özür dilerim
neyi
çıkış akımına
veririm?
o s
s
d